today
msnbc was caught
jury tampering
now fortunately it was attempted jury
tampering but apparently an msnbc
producer was trailing the jury bus
blowing through a street light to try
and keep up with them
and of course they they come out and
they say this is a normal process it's
is you know they were just trying to get
in touch with the jurors so they could
interview them after the verdict
right the judge banned msnbc from the
building
now this producer that was named uh is
an nbc producer so this you know of
course overlap but this may be one of
the most serious
i don't know how you just uh
acts of aggression what are you gonna
what do you want to call it attempts to
interfere
grave constitutional violations november
9th i believe it was fox news everyone
reported i mean i was watching the trial
the judge said someone tried to film the
jury at the bus pickup we will change
protocol it won't happen again so don't
tell me these msnbc producers did not
know what they were doing was in
violation of the judge's rules and i
believe criminal some have reported it
was a felony to try and do what they did
we have more evidence
this this story gets crazy i believe i
have a case
to present to you
that ada krauss
tampered with evidence to cheat because
they knew they would lose
i believe i can spell it out for you
very clearly now that being said i'm not
going to claim it's definitive but i can
show you the evidence
he has software on his computer for
cropping and for formatting i believe he
got the footage himself from tucker
carlson's show cropped out the fox news
graphic compressed it to give the
defense a a a version they could not
form an argument around
and then he got caught
now maybe it's speculative but wait till
we show you the transcript and you see
what he said i believe he outed himself
and he got caught
will the judge declare a mistrial with
prejudice will he declare a mistrial he
could rule on either because both
motions have been raised
he said a day of reckoning he said i
warned you a day of reckoning would come
over this video
but we'll wait to see what the jury says
now if the jury comes back with not
guilty it's moot but
some rumors are circulating it's a 6-6
hung jury that they're not in agreement
guilty and not guilty right in the
middle
and so what will the judge do i don't
know but this is a travesty of justice
so we'll go through that we've got some
other uh stories talk about the national
guard in oklahoma refusing the vaccine
and being threatened to be disbanded
effectively to be they would be kicked
out of the national guard and they would
just become militia apparently that's
what what the pentagon said we'll get
into all that stuff joining us to talk
about all of this stuff today is
filmmaker ben stewart good to be back
this is my third time go to ben
josephstewart.com and look me up on
youtube ben stewart got a lot of uh
really good news and i have to say that
uh i listen to the daily show every day
tim i get some really good stuff from
there i appreciate it yeah man well glad
to have you back it's always a pleasure
we did that first episode on the fourth
turning and going through the book and
everything so we might get into that
stuff again as well because that's a
very crazy topic especially with how
crazy everything's getting yeah we got
luke chillin yeah last year i was here i
was like you guys got to get ben in here
it's good to see finally you here three
times now finally i'm here when you're
here so i'm really happy about that me
and me and ben go back all the way back
till 2010. that's right and uh yeah it's
great to see you and uh today i am
wearing a shirt that is highlighting a
fresh pack of dopamine addicting doctor
recommended modern day pack of
cigarettes with big tech of course
representing the cigarettes individually
put in there you could get yours
exclusively to show disdain
towards our totalitarian overlords on
the
bestpoliticoshirts.com and because you
do i'm here thanks for having me
when they're young
exactly
you know it feels like a hurricane went
through here the last few days and now
we're like sitting in the very calm in
the calm nice silence it is silent you
know
that's weird it's like the ghost of of
of alex and rogan still are like perfect
yes yes
thank you guys to be honest we had a
million and one people trying to you
know we want to come i'm going to come
and i was like i think we need to just
have a calmer single guest like we would
normally do thank you
tripp's been fantastic but
you know we're going to have uh two
people on tomorrow so it'll be a big
show again but it's been a blast here we
got lydia pressing the buttons thank you
guys for joining me in the kitchen once
again as we're chilling in austin this
is a really cool city we did some really
fun stuff about to post to my instagram
it was incredible this is such a fun
city and i'm so glad we're here let's
get started before we do get started
head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com if you would
like a virtual private network service
from virtual shield first i'll shout out
virtual shields my first sponsor they
came to me back when i was a very tiny
small youtube channel and they've been
with me ever since so i'm extremely
grateful to their support in helping all
of this come into fruition virtual
shield is a virtual private network
service the basic layer of security for
you as you browse the web there are
hackers government agents evil
corporations that want to they want to
take your data they want to sell it they
want to use it against you and if you
want a basic level of protection nothing
perfect but good enough something to
keep you safe go to surfing internet
safe dot com they say stay safe with 50
percent off for life
enjoy 24 months of online security from
the world's easiest and fastest vpn for
only 59.88 that's actually 77 off but
that 50 percent is all of their add-ons
and other great discounts the way to
describe it to people is
you don't expect someone to break into
your house but you lock your doors and
windows if you're browsing the web and
you want that basic layer of security
and there's a bunch a bunch of other
really great benefits about vpns that
you should definitely check out go to
surfinginternetsafe.com and my final
thought on this to shout out a virtual
shield is
these are the companies that are willing
to sponsor shows
like this freedom
that there's there's so much cancel
culture you know post millennials
getting getting attacked all the time so
these are the companies you guys should
be supporting if you want a vpn support
companies that support you
also don't forget go to timcast.com
become a member and you will get access
to our members only segments we're gonna
have a members only segment coming up at
around 11 or so p.m you don't want to
miss that plus we're hiring a couple
more journalists for the team and your
membership helps support that don't
forget to like this video right now
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel take that url share it wherever
you can because that's the most powerful
thing you can do to help the show if
you're a fan let's get into that first
story and this my friends is a doozy
from the new york post
msnbc banned from kyle rittenhouse trial
after producer accused of following
jurors accused the police caught the
person and took them into custody issued
them traffic citations this person
following the jury bus from the written
house trial blew a stoplight to try and
keep up with them
that's crazy huh dang let's read a
little bit they say
the man who identified himself as james
morrison was pulled over wednesday after
he allegedly blew a red light while
pursuing a bus to transport jurors he
stated he had been instructed by a
superior in new york to follow the jury
bus now we have the name i'm not going
to say the name of this producer because
we have no evidence the producer was
actually doing anything and a lot of
people are accusing this producer of
malintent i can tell you this the police
said this guy was doing this thing he
may have just tried throwing a producer
under the bus by being like oh it's my
boss my boss made me do it i don't have
evidence of that but i can say the
producer in question purged their social
media across the board i watched it
happen in real time that could just be
because people are piling on because the
judge said their names i don't think the
judge should have to be completely
honest i think the judge should have
called out this guy
but i'll tell you this
msnbc
knew
nbc knew
that this was jury tampering the judge
had already warned about filming the
jury the police said they believed the
man was trying to photograph jurors
and now it gets worse
the judge says
the bus is blacked out
so they can't see in or out the jurors
you know how bad that is
that's not a good thing and he said it
was because we don't want the jurors to
see anything from either side
how thick do you think the wall of a bus
is a millimeter
of steel
when that bus drives past the courthouse
to screaming to bull horning those
jurors can hear it all you can block the
light but you can't block the sound and
the bus goes by and everybody knows you
mean to tell me that you blacked out the
bus or they couldn't see
people got bull horns these people are
being brought into the courtroom
under this guard because of these
protests two people got arrested for
fighting a dude got arrested for having
a knife these jurors know it jury
tampering in my opinion it's here
now the craziest bit of this
msnbc
corporate actors
this is
i mean what would you describe this as
it's not activism it's work it's crazier
than that uh mike cernovich wrote about
this today and he said msnbc
cross state lines to jury tamper and i i
think there's a case to be made here
especially with how biased msnbc has
been about this entire case i mean joy
reid was just on her nationally
syndicated television show talking about
how kyle crying is just white man tears
which she doesn't care about she called
kyle karen she compared them to to
kavanaugh and and these are people with
obviously a bent they want a particular
outcome in this story so to to think
that they're innocent here i think is a
misnomer we're still waiting to find out
all the details we don't know exactly
what was going on here but uh we do we
do i mean i mean as far as like the
bigger details the exact intentions
whether this is going to be criminally
charged or not we don't know that but
but i posted a meme about this today on
my twitter account and it's and it shows
uh michael myers and halloween with the
tagline msnbc creeping on jurors so uh
you know we got to laugh at this thing
because it's ridiculous this is and i i
think you know from my own personal view
this was more malicious than than it was
investigative journalism investigating
investigating a jury who's being
protected from public exposure well
that's the other side of the story
they're saying i think it was last week
i should we did a segment on this show
where i played an msnbc video
where they said gage gross kreutz
testified he had his hands up when he
was shot and then they play a video from
the trial of something totally different
of him talking about how he was scared
for his life and wanted to be an emt and
i'm like that's not the testimony and
then we played the video where the
defense said it wasn't until you
advanced on kyle and pointed your gun at
him that he shot you and he says yes so
what the what was msnbc talking about
then we get people saying i haven't
watched msnbc to this capacity but
they're like they show the prosecutor's
closing argument and they don't show the
defense
now
msnbc was attempting to expose the
identities of the jurors the police said
let me show you this kenosha police
department said police suspect this
person was trying to photograph jurors
is this i'll tell you this i think it is
but is this
a major corporate player
ideologues cultists
trying to affect the outcome of a trial
and if so for what reason
i was just going to say like
what if they would have gotten pictures
like what story can they run with right
what were they going for they probably
would have leaked it
but to what end like what would msnbc's
angle be like hey check this out what's
the tagline
hey we got some pictures they they could
have said they i mean when i got
attacked in germany by antifa it was a
mainstream media journalist that took a
picture of me and gave it out to all the
anti-fall members to come targeted and
attack me and then they lied about the
entire situation so there could be msnbc
journalists i mean they're acting more
and more like activists so they have a
network of activists that work for them
that obviously have connections to all
the large organized protests that have
been happening all throughout this
country i'm speculating here we have no
solid proof or evidence of this but it's
not far to speculate with just the
atrocious actions that msnbc has been
taken on the intelligence of the
american people with their blasphemy and
bull crap that they've been trying to
shove down everyone's throat it's
ridiculous what they've been saying
they've been off the rails and they've
been more concerned about an agenda a
narrative rather than of course any kind
of even semblance of news reporting
because they haven't been doing any of
that uh and i think that's a fair
argument to make here with everything
that's going on here and it's just it's
just ridiculous some people are saying
that this is clear obstruction of
justice some people are saying that they
wanted to the jury to know that they're
watching them some people say that they
wanted the jury know that they have
their identities who knows but but
either way this stinks to high heaven
we're going to find out later down the
line what's going to happen here i'm
just speculating i could see like um
them wanting to prep a story like meet
the jurors from the kyle written how and
they have all of them already planned
and they already know who each of them
are and they find out where what about
so and then they're just willing to
throw this reporter under the bus
they're like what's worse is gonna
happen we're gonna get sued for 10
million bucks if we could find that
found out so why or or this guy will go
to prison for uh for a felony and
they're like we don't care we didn't do
it yeah whatever throw him under the bus
they're probably not gonna even cover
his lawyer fees like oh def yeah
probably not they're going to be they
they've already said i think it was like
a rogue producer
they're trying to claim like uh so so
this was crazy when the story with story
broke the police said a man alleging to
be with the national outlet
all of a sudden you know i'm watching
the the live stream for the trial and
it's just nothing it's just the emblem
right then all of a sudden the noise the
sound turns on the judge steps up and
i'm like this could be a verdict what is
this and the judge said here's what
happened claiming to be with msnbc now i
didn't know if that was true because i
was like guys you know i tweeted for all
we know this is antifa pretending to be
a reporter and and knowing someone's
name and throwing them under the bus
trying to escape the cops like let's be
chill about this a reporter from court
tv said i know the guy yes he does work
for this organization and this is a
normal practice
sounds to me
i will i won't give him the benefit of
the doubt i won't play that game anymore
you could argue that msnbc was just like
we're gonna get a scoop and everyone
else be damned no i'm not going to buy
it when msnbc lies about the testimony
of the state witness to make the state
look better when they cut out the
defense's arguments when joy reed goes
on her show and says white male tears
they want to affect the outcome the
reason those protesters are outside
screaming at these at these as the bus
is coming in to drop off jurors is
because of the likes of msnbc and others
like them so they definitely want to
affect the outcome in my opinion this
dude may have been a useful idiot but i
think they were like get the jurors
information and you made a great point
ben to what end to what story would they
do they can't they can't do a story when
this when the show's over maybe and
maybe they're hoping they have more
information on the jurors than anybody
else they could find them fast but
either way
if the jury finds out they're being
trailed and they i'm apparent apparently
did right that's jury intimidation right
so what
you think the jurors after the fact are
going to be like oh that was you who was
following us in this in this landmark
trial we're terrified of the outcome of
and making us fear for our lives of
course i'll do an interview with you
let's make a statement why not yeah i i
can't i can't follow like ever hear like
a dog chase in the car like dog doesn't
know what he would do if he got the car
i'm really curious like what would they
have done if they would have gotten the
moment
sorry i've seen a dog get the car and
what happened was it hit the wheels from
when the car was going 50 miles an hour
and went flying up in the air and was
torn away good metaphor for what
happened to this person in msnbc you
know
what good could have come out of it for
for this guy or for msnbc i knew what he
was doing he knew what he was doing
right of course he did
this is not about getting a scoop this
is
how could this be anything other than a
form of jury intimidation and
obstruction of justice regardless of
intent it was
tampering obstruction i don't know about
observation of justice i think that
applies to like law enforcement
investigation but this regardless of
intent they were tampering with the jury
it's such a huge trial i mean like
biggest of our lifetime menendez
brothers it didn't fit everything that
was going on in the world this fits
everything that's going on in the world
and i i really feel i was talking to
lydia beforehand like you take a look at
this like yes it's
they're making it into something like
black versus white but really it's
somebody it's the only armed citizenry
in the world protecting small businesses
during a time where there's an all-out
assault on small businesses
and really it's this is like an iconic
symbolic show of force against anyone
who wants to
defend small businesses by any means the
race thing really is crazy too and the
ideology thing is crazy because i keep
seeing the left saying he showed up in
opposition to black lives matter and i
was like no one ever said that one time
the testimony from the state witnesses
and the defense was that he rendered aid
to the black lives matter protesters
sounds like he was there to help them
but but also stop riots right so it's
not like he's like i hate you no he's
like i'm here to help you but please
don't burn anything down this is
unprecedented though i mean like
i'm trying to think of another time in
history let's just say in the past
hundred years where there have been such
violent
riots around the country that people in
mass had had to start calling in
local favors and say like could you come
and protect our business because
car cart blanche is just being destroyed
across the board has that ever happened
well in the 90s there was uh riots in
los angeles there was racial riots in
new york as well and then of course in
the 60s and 70s there was a lot of riots
as well so this is not something that's
that's you know where people brought
their own
guns to protect small businesses there's
there's
the rooftops the rooftop koreans are of
course talked about a lot especially in
the chat room um and and you know
this is not what
what went down in the la riots and why
the the koreatown residents you know
took to their rooftops the police left
they were like what do you expect us to
do about it i believe i don't know if it
was the national guard or the army that
was brought in but they formed a
perimeter and so you have all of these
people just being like we've been
abandoned
completely yeah don't be surprised when
the state abandons you the police aren't
going to protect you like we saw in
kenosha they will leave so what happens
you know there's that famous viral
moment where the guy was pulled i say
viral but this is historical where he
was pulled out of the truck in the early
riots and brutally beaten and stomped on
the ground and left you know seriously
injured and then during the george floyd
riots the blm riot the great blm riots
of 2020
25 people are confirmed to have been
dead due to those riots now if you go by
the periphery like uh related incidents
around the riots i believe it goes up to
like 34 33 33 maybe
and they also found uh after a building
was burned down and completely destroyed
they didn't realize this but after they
cleared the rubble they found a body oh
man so you have you have these stories
and don't don't be surprised when people
come out now the problem is
when someone like kyle rittenhouse comes
out he shouldn't have and he shouldn't
have had to but the rider shouldn't have
been there and if the riders did the
police should have stopped them but the
police didn't
this is what ends up happening now the
trial for kyle rittenhouse as you
mentioned this is a question of whether
or not
regular people have a right to say no to
the extremists destroying their
neighborhoods and as we can see with how
merrick garland has been handling the ag
how how he's been handling the doj as ag
going after parents concerned about
critical race theory instead of the
extremists and the riots
and
i mean i think it's fair to say we know
who's being protected on this one not
just going after parents but using
counter terrorism division
members and using threat tags to go
after specific parents because they went
after they went to a pta meeting that's
absolutely absurd and just highlights
the insanity of the political
persecution that's going after people
for their beliefs rather for their than
for their actions i got um
i've got a theory for you guys briefly
mention it before the show but for
everybody watching i believe that ada
krauss in the written house trial
manufactured evidence
i should say this manipulated evidence
provided a weakened version of that
evidence of the defense in an effort to
disadvantage them prejudice the jury and
gain a hail mary pass which in fact has
now given them a potential hung jury to
simplify
drone footage they're calling it unicorn
evidence emerges you know right in the
middle of the trial that the the state
has
they present it they claim it shows kyle
right now is pointing his weapon at the
zaminski's provoking rosenbaum to attack
him
now you can't really see much here's
what we know is true
the evidence that they presented was not
the same evidence given to the defense
the defense was provided with a i
believe it was uh two uh was it like a
212 p video a lower resolution and
apparently a cropped version
so when the defense is reviewing the
video they say i can't see anything here
they're claiming that this shows written
house pointing the weapon the jury will
never buy it the video's too blurry and
grainy
but then they go to trial they go they
go into the trial and the jury is given
higher res video instead now what ends
up happening is the defense didn't
notice this they crafted their argument
around you can't see anything anyway but
in the high-res video it's easier to see
and then the state made their argument
the defense was unable to provide a
defense because they were not given the
evidence it wasn't until the judge said
i want to see this
the the defense played their low-res
version and the judge says what is this
i can't see anything
bingor one of the prosecutors says our
version is clearer isn't it and kraus
says yes
this results in shock among the judge
and the defense saying what do you mean
how is yours clear we weren't provided
that evidence and then kraus says
no it's just playing weird that line
right there
is evidence to me he realized uh oh i've
been caught now you may be saying tim
that's a wild theory but i've brought
receipts i send you now to my twitter
where i produced a thread now this is
not definitive it is just my hypothesis
as to what may have occurred
i think it's possible i'm wrong because
there are some elements here and i'll
explain but first take a look at this
we have a an image from election whiz he
says based on the work of john m curtis
death not
it appears the written house drone video
was a cropped version of the video shown
on tucker carlson so the image i'm
presenting now on the screen for those
that are watching you can see the tucker
carlson video and you can see the
prosecution's video and it looks like
someone cropped out fox news's graphic
creating a strange video now here's the
point i made the drone footage presented
by the state is in a weird format
1920x844
what resolution is that i mean nobody
it's it's 1080. this appears to be
because the full video was manipulated
to remove either the graphic or
something the state did not want to
include and that's me speculating
because i don't know who cropped that
video they may have received it from
somebody else but i brought receipts i
want to say how did the footage get
cropped kraus on his laptop has format
factory and i have the source right here
included in my tweet in the image you
can see format factory it's kind of hard
to see
format factory is software that allows
you to crop mix transcode video but crop
is highlighted on their website i point
this out format factory is not just
transcoding as per their website it also
crops video this explains why kraus had
handbrake and format factory here's the
source it says provides audio and video
converter splitter mixer crop and d logo
was kraus looking for software that
would remove the fox news graphic d logo
and then decided to crop it instead into
a strange format that doesn't make sense
now i'm going to pause for a second and
say this
at any rate
shouldn't this be called into question
your honor videos aren't recorded in
844p
this video has been tampered with
the video should be if it's 1920 it
should be 1920x1080
i'd argue that this has got something
cut out and thus should not be used now
they might say too bad the video shows
what it shows but i think right away
there's an issue let's move on now i
said now we all know it's a fact the
defense was given a lower res video this
is not disputed but it seems ada kraus
got caught as per the transcript there's
a transcript of the moment when the
defense realized they were not given the
real evidence in fact they were given a
low res version two things stand out
bingor says this isn't the same quality
as our version is it sounds like bingo
didn't know i mean the dude seems to be
rather inept and doesn't know gun safety
but i think from the transcript he
genuinely didn't know kraus says no our
version's much clearer wisco for the
defense says i got that from you
i have the advanced one but that is
exactly what we got from you we got it
from dropbox the judge says so what
you're showing me now is this doesn't
show anything this is what was provided
to the defense
richards on the defense says yes
bingor says mr stoot is on his way this
is their tech guy who's now going to
come in and play the high-res version
wisco says i don't know that's what we
got from dropbox so if your version's
clear that means you didn't give us our
give us your version and kraus says it's
just playing weird holy cow wisco says
that's not how it works
if it truly was a mistake that somehow
this is what they argued when they sent
the video over email because they send
it over email it somehow changed the
name of the file and and compressed it
that's not possible that doesn't happen
but krause said it's just playing weird
why would he say that it's just playing
weird he offered up an excuse to try and
placate everybody who realized
somebody was manipulating the evidence
that to me is the quote in question
if krause genuinely didn't know this
happened he'd have been like i don't
know why it's doing it i have no idea
what's going on or you said nothing is i
don't know our version seems to be clear
something must have gone wrong we'll fix
it i'm sorry instead he says no no it's
just playing weird
check it out
not only was the video compressed the
prosecution appears to have provided a
cropped version now there's a potential
explanation for this in the top video
you can see the car to the left in the
bottom video you can see there's much
more space behind the car the video is
cropped this could be the result of
whoever uploaded this comparison to
youtube so i don't know for sure we do
know that 480 by 2 by 12
is
not the same as 1920 by 844 and both are
strange formats there's also an
explanation for how it got de-rezzed
some people say that when you when you
when you put a 1920x844
in email on iphone the iphone will
compress it now that may be the case but
there's no reason to give them the
benefit of the doubt and i have more
they say the file name that was given to
the fence had a
was different okay now itunes won't do
that i'm sorry not itunes uh iphone will
not ios a smaller file size and a
different file name but what will change
a file name compression software which
again is on kraus's computer known as
handbrake which many people have pointed
out below format factory handbrake is
transcoding software can render videos
easily to other sizes and formats source
from handbrake.fr they say it's a tool
for converting video from nearly any
format to a selection of modern widely
supported codecs
the original format 1920x1080 somehow
got cropped to 1920x844
it gets further cropped renamed and
compressed
so there are potential explanations i
don't have
that that's as far as i go with you know
presenting my case as far as i can uh uh
what i'll basically say is i believe
beyond uh this is probable cause
i believe i have shown probable cause to
believe that ada kraus tampered with
evidence to try and cheat and win and
and disadvantage the defense and
prejudice the jury against the defendant
i don't know if it's definitive i don't
know if he actually did these things but
handbrake as many people have described
as in the weeds software you got to be
like to know what that is because it's
fairly obscure format factory to have
both cropping software and compression
software when a video is compressed and
cropped raises a lot of questions and
for crowds to say it's it's just playing
weird it was a weird thing to say to try
to make excuses i think we have enough
to do this the process the judge has
said
uh he has implied he wants kraus to go
under oath on the stand
do it
and we'll see what happens
now the judge has said there will be a
reckoning on this software
on this video i'm sorry
but he's going to wait for the jury to
come back with their verdict so we'll
see how that plays out but let me know
what you guys think about that rant i
just did on all that evidence and do you
agree with me you did a very good job of
compiling and i'm glad you got the
images to show there my only question is
this is a big case right
how was none of this checked beforehand
i mean as a video guy i'm i'm curious
because i was saying earlier on an image
to see whether it's been doctored or not
you can check to see how many dates of
of creation it has on it if it only has
one date of creation that means that was
the date it was taken and it hasn't been
touched since
how did they not look into that and why
did they go to tucker carlson and
whatever like you know screen record or
something i don't i don't know if they
got it from tucker carlson
some people have pointed out the video
appears to be the same footage that came
from tucker carlson but it's cropped so
what i'm simply saying is this to me
seems plausible but that's why i said
uh um probable cause probable cause is
not proof beyond a reasonable doubt i'm
just saying all this stuff lines up and
he's got these two specific programs for
this
i'd like to get him under oath and
investigate that you did a great job and
the fact that you're here talking about
this
like this is a huge case beforehand
wouldn't they ask questions like where
did you get this evidence i want to
investigate to make sure that what
you're saying lines up with where this
imagery comes from
why is the file format
on a non-standard format and why are you
the first one i'm hearing that from you
know 844p i mean when i when i saw that
and right away i was like huh yeah
everybody
you know you know i've been doing video
editing since i was like 10 or 11 years
old i started with flash four so i don't
know how that was i was a little kid
i've had a computer i've been doing
paint brush since windows came out i've
always had a computer i did flash i was
doing after effects i started making
skate videos in after effects because
i'm a little kid has no idea what he's
doing and then i started getting into uh
other editing software making skate
videos i've been working in video
editing my whole life and computers and
all that stuff i've developed apps and i
saw this and i'm like
that's not a normal thing someone sent
this and it's and it's clearly a
manipulated video but the defense is not
technologically
savvy savvy yeah right
a good example is when they were trying
to explain algorithmic um enlargement
and the the defense said they use a 3d
ai logarithm to to produce and generate
and i was like oh
you guys don't know what they're saying
it's image interpolation you can simply
say i understand what he was trying to
say but it uses a computer program
to
predict what the image may look like it
is not an image from the night in
question very simply very simply stated
they didn't have a firearms expert they
didn't have somebody who could speak
more clearly to that does i mean i'm
gonna i'm gonna go back to saying this
is a huge case how much ineptitude
are we seeing here because like i i'm
i'm just shocked that everything that
you're breaking down here
is not something that had been thought
of or talked about before this is a huge
case like what what's going on someone
someone actually super chatted that i've
demonstrated means motive and
opportunity that's right um yeah
look look look
sure
but you we need an investigation
we need to we need forensic ima we need
forensic analysis on his computer i want
to see when he down we know when he had
those programs he's had him since
january january 7th he had a handbrake i
want people say you can see the last
time it was used sort of we i want i
want to know when the uh uh the
defense's file was generated when it was
when the when the 212 video was created
i want to see when the defenses was
created and then i want to look at his
computer
i want to get him under oath they should
seize his laptop immediately how much
you want to bet he's already doing a dod
sweep on it purging the hard drive seven
times over yep of course yeah wow
because he probably knows this is coming
like by the way i mean now we're not
talking krause bingers is like hearing
his voice it sounds like you're
listening to somebody in junior high
right right i already feel like i'm in
idiocracy
where it's like
you don't have to do that good of a job
to get by with your job these days
so this is one of the things i noticed
as i was growing up was that all of our
institutions are like held together by
spider webs like no one is checking
things like and i i when i do my work i
try to go back and check everything i've
done because i worked in a hospital and
if you don't check things and make sure
that your documentation is correct you
can be in huge trouble you can use your
license the nurse in charge of you can
use their license but apparently this is
in this case in this huge freaking trial
and i just wanted to say that i feel
like we don't owe this prosecution any
form of confidence that they are
operating in good faith because they're
not even competent so if this super chat
is correct i think it backs up exactly
what i said so uh so a super chat said
why cow has the metadata the video the
defense received was created 20 minutes
after the original if genuine they'd
show the same if it was created 20
minutes after the original that would
imply that krause
was the one who made both
he made the original file they admitted
as evidence and then he made the lower
res version to give the defense to
weaken their ability to to argue against
this trial because if because if it was
if it was a third party who made both
how would he have two different files
and then give the wrong one that's
possible it's possible somebody made
both files gave both a low resident
high-res version i don't know why they
would do that
and then the prosecution had the two
files sent the wrong one over the
defense
maybe
i was in the military for six years and
i learned that oversight is just built
into the system you have oversight so
like
i hope nobody's going to claim oh okay
this was a mistake it was an accident
there's got to be oversight so these
accidents don't happen exactly
i i'm i'm
really perplexed right now kind of
flabbergasted i'm going to say it one
more time this is a high profile case
let's talk about the ram site let's talk
about the ramifications of this fake
evidence
the the prosecution won a major victory
when they were able to get the judge to
instruct the jury on provocation
if you believe that cal written house
provoked the attack then he must have
exhausted all means of retreat otherwise
it is not self-defense i think something
that effect
and
if they didn't have this video footage
with that argument about him pointing
the weapon there would have been no prop
provocation instruction the juror would
have been told he was attacked if you
believe he acted in self defense or quit
here's what we got from newsmax and i
don't know if this is true but this is
newsmax reporting
a smack source reports they overheard
kyle reddenhouse's attorney saying that
he believed the jury is at a six six
split mike carter reports from the
courthouse in kenosha
it could be a hung jury
we've already heard rumors uh jack
pasobic said he had a source claiming
that there were two holdouts that that
uh he said you know ten people were in
agreement two were holding out we that
could mean that ten wanted to convict i
mean the two didn't it could mean that
ten wanted to acquit and two didn't we
don't know for sure
but one thing that's interesting is that
the defense made a verbal motion for
mistrial
straight up mistrial
that would mean written house would be
tried again
we mentioned this the other day
cernovich said it's it's an advantage
for the for the defense they'll get to
do this whole thing over knowing exactly
what the state has
and
here's what people have missed
if everything i said about krauss and
the manipulation of this evidence is
true it will get thrown out and the
state will have no opportunity to
present that furthermore
if krause did do something untoward he
could get in serious trouble and the
case may actually
something beyond a retrial may happen if
it turns out that they did something
malicious it could actually it might not
be with prejudice but it may actually
create a political pressure where they
can't retry kyle rittenhouse so
if we're looking at a hung jury
and the defense is like okay we're going
to do we're going to get a do-over let's
add a verbal motion for mistrial what
people need to know is the judge has
both motions to consider the judge could
rule either way it's just more
options for the defense
i keep thinking about how the how the
jurors are coming in on a bus where they
can't see anything but they hear
screaming people screaming at them they
the people outside know who it's like if
you're led into a courthouse blindfolded
and people all around you are screaming
at you as you're walking in how
horrifying and mind-twisting that would
be and then to have to
to decide the fate of of basically those
the people outside as well the the
people that are screaming at you
your
that well someone's decisions gonna
weigh on if i rule this way will there
be consequences and other people hurt
because of the way i roll so that's also
another aspect that we have to consider
here when we have these kind of
egregious cases of people trying to make
photos of them people following them the
people screaming outside of them so so
there's a lot to to play into this but
what did the judge rule because i know
the defense said mistrial with prejudice
then then they reached for mistrial
without prejudice um what was his kind
of understanding of this did he did he
decide on it or did he say i'm going to
wait until this journey comes out the
first time uh the defense made a verbal
motion for mistrial with prejudice
the judge said i'll take it under
advisement and then he basically was
like if there's one more violation you
guys watch yourself
they made a formal the filing for
emotion uh mishra with prejudice
we didn't hear him we didn't hear
anything about that from the judge the
verbal motion for mistrial the judge
basically said i'm gonna wait till the
jury comes back with a verdict and we'll
see excuse me hiccups
i'm so i'm really curious here like
maybe like anyone's opinion on like
what's what's the impact gonna be is is
there any way that this can go where the
impact of what's happening in kenosha
would be different do you think it's
it's just gonna escalate no matter what
yep well you got the mainstream media
putting fuel on the fire you got the
mainstream media screaming going crazy
trying to make this a race issue and
it's not you got the mainstream media
sorry corporate media as as malice would
call them literally fanning the flames
here in every instant just like they did
um last summer yeah so with that
happening i mean people were like
guaranteeing that something was going to
happen we don't know exactly but the
conditions that created previous civil
unrest are there for this current period
now there there's different times we're
not going through the summer the summer
is usually the hot period where there is
a lot of civil unrest but there are
memes going around showing ron paul at
the federal reserve disguising it with a
nike store saying that this is a meme
this is not a real image but it's a meme
saying that he hopes that during rioting
season people will target the federal
reserve and think oh i love it
but but so so there's already wasn't
there a babylon b article about that or
something like i believe so yeah
oh no what have the writers done i've
seen the meme and i have to share the
meme uh because it hit home to what's
really going on here uh but but who
knows what's going to happen here the
conditions are there we can only hope
and do our best to try to provide a
reasonable side of the story to try to
provide some kind of explanation that
will decrease the risk of violence and
escalation but the escalation has been
there it's significant and i think it's
only going to get even more significant
the judge
should have declared a mistrial with
prejudice immediately
because
what people have been saying and what
the judge is saying is you know he's
gonna wait for the verdict if it's a not
guilty verdict then the rulings are
irrelevant
the problem is
then the j then the prosecution goes we
got away with it
we tried our best
we cheated to our hearts content but we
didn't win
that means they could do it again
now there's also the potential warning
that if a guilty verdict you know issue
if a guilty verdict does come in the
judge could be like mistrial with
prejudice blame this blame the
prosecutors
well yeah there's a story
there's definitely a story no matter
which way this swings there's a story to
escalate it i feel i think it was
katherine austin fitz she did some
research on the the 2020 riots alone and
she said
i may get the numbers wrong but 35 out
of 37 of the the main parts of the
damage done to infrastructure was done
right around maybe within a quarter or a
half mile of a central bank and her
whole theory like i mean
again this is just her theory saying
that like you know this is exactly where
they're gonna build up the smart grid
you know so i don't know i'm not gonna
press on that one but i i love when i
hear people outside the box
investigation being like i'm just going
to look at what else there is around all
these spots that seem to be
unnecessarily damaged what is the smart
grid exactly well a smart
so you know the internet of things it's
part of their 2030 plan for all major
urban cities to be digitized and to be
run through a kind of uh sorry i cut you
off that but to be run through a kind of
centralized grid
it's totally centralized and it's it's
the device you know over in china i
think robert spaulding was talking about
this and his i forget what book stealth
wars or something like that but he was
saying like over in china
there's not even the need for the device
anymore because there's so many cameras
and microphones um that the very next
step is you walk out your door and you
say uber it acknowledges who you are by
your voice or where you're standing and
the camera and it comes by and picks you
up and you're in the device so the smart
grid is definitely what what luke was
saying about it's it's creating the
internet of things everywhere and mind
you smart dust was being talked about in
2000 going into pavement and it's
already there in denver
that's a big that's a big rabbit hole
but also in china if you jaywalk they
take a photo of you they don't you don't
need to show your identification you
don't need to report to anyone they take
a photo of you and a fine automatically
is deducted from your bank account and
you get a notification on your phone
you've been you've been punished for
jaywalking on this street and we took
this money out of your bank account
that's the smart grid smart dust you're
taking us down the rabbit hole i like
this bed finally we're getting we're
getting started here i like this
this is some uh this is down the rabbit
hole stuff that i think we need to go
down into allison i'll just say this
allison mcdowell you know is talking
about um where we're moving is total
gamification um by 6g everyone will have
uh like up to 12 digital twins so
avatars
and um all connected to this thing
called the sentient world simulation
which is a if you've seen the last
season of uh westworld it's basically a
digital mirror of this world but in real
time and i forget what their prediction
was but when it gets to minority report
level where it can start predicting
people's actions what groups you'll end
up in what stores you'll end up at when
why where those steps this is the
digitization of everything this is mark
zuckerberg's metaverse but in real life
but but and this is how they're going to
do it you're going to be in the pod
eating the bugs living in the society
where they will track trace and database
every aspect of your existence to
the nanoparticle of
smart intelligent dust and and and
microchip particles that will be in
charge of controlling every aspect of
your human existence so colonization all
the way down to our biology just look up
international barcode of life and see
who some of the main donors to that
thank you mr gates yeah mr bill gates i
was just going to say gatesgate
so hold on so this is this is a big
segue right we're talking about a
potential hung jury in a criminal trial
coincidence sorry i just got off i went
up you guys you guys just like blasted
off yeah
but but but i have a question i mean
are you saying that you think that the
riots and all the destruction we've seen
is somehow tied to
i'll just put it simply i mean i think
it's fair to say an attempt to gain more
control politically over people's lives
and i think if you walk back from the
smart dust stuff you know there's
something that's kind of freaky for
people to understand and you said
something like you know why is the
police stand down and allow the riots
why is it that the media promotes them
why did kamala harris fundraise for them
the violence scares people and triggers
a response where they say give us more
money to keep you safe
yeah you know like i'm just theorizing
here um i've i've been looking into this
i think last time we talked about agenda
20 uh 2020 down to 2030 and everything
like that i personally feel like you've
talked about davos you've talked about
world economic forum the whole idea is
moving from stakeholder capitalism to
shareholders or maybe it's the other way
shareholder capitalism to stakeholder
capitalism you need an excuse to
radically
not just homogenize world economies and
bring them all together under one but
you need an excuse a public facing
excuse so to me and this is yet again
another thing that um catherine austin
fitz says is like invisible threats are
great you can like call terrorism for
one and you can't tell who's the
terrorist you know it could be anyone it
could be your neighbor be very
suspicious of your neighbors type of
thing
the um covet
the well exactly and so the idea about
it is like again this is just a theory
but like i definitely feel that davos
wants to succeed in this great reset and
so the forward facing like what's the
excuse how do we tell the the future
generations why this whole thing went
down
um i'm not saying that like what's
happening right now is fake and i'm not
saying that anything along those lines
but opportunizing the never let a good
crisis go to waste exactly and so to me
i absolutely feel that this needs to be
spun
in this direction and and i'll just take
it back to what i said about the kyle
rittenhouse case and why it's so iconic
is because
it's a it's a man a 17 year old with a
rifle
at
in front of small businesses which are
being i mean i think i saw a woman today
saying i i run a shop in kenosha 50
of shops have been shut down small
businesses shut down they never reopened
a lot of them are moving out of the area
there's something happening if you if
you like to call it all a coincidence
that's fine i i personally don't mind
taking several leaps of faith in order
to at least take
think of what it could be what could be
happening because you'll never get the
full story the the uh
you know i don't like the big conspiracy
stuff i think it gets too grandiose and
it makes too many assumptions and i
think there's actually some evidence to
suggest this is definition never let a
good crisis go to waste and that is when
the covet stuff first started you were
not allowed to talk about it on social
media it was the craziest thing when the
first news came out of wuhan of the
weird stuff i made some videos on
youtube youtube didn't notice didn't
care then there was this period where
they were like you cannot talk about
this you'll be demonetized and they're
exerting pressure on channels that were
actually saying hey there's an outbreak
i think initially
that the the establishment was like this
is panic stuff we don't want anyone
talking about this and then once it hit
and and the establishment politicians
are like wait wait wait wait wait wait
we can use this we can use the crisis 15
days becomes two years
then all of a sudden youtube's like
actually we're gonna allow you to start
talking about it and then truth be told
when the more and more videos are
popping up about it this the fear
spreads and it allows a lot more
uh corrupt politicians and powerful ceos
big pharma corporations to be like now's
our chance to use fear to gain power
i mean there's different realms of
thinking here but there's a lot of setup
here especially by individuals like bill
gates that wasn't just funneling money
into the mainstream media because he
gave he gave hundreds of billions of
dollars to the mainstream media that
buys a lot of influence he they're smart
people who know what's going on i just
i'm sorry i mean if we could it's so
annoying to do the cliche bill gates no
no no it's important to mention here
because this is a man that has far more
influence than we even know about and we
already know hundreds of millions of
dollars to the mainstream media a new
report just give me some evidence other
than the guy says stupid things to the
press
he doesn't say stupid things to the
press he buys off the press he gave them
319 million dollars to media outlets
like cnn nbc npr the atlantic the bbc
the guardian all are on his payroll all
on his paycheck what does that mean talk
about the way that he positions himself
in society especially what does it mean
what does it mean things like the
vaccine industry
explain to me beyond i saw a guy do a
bunch of things that make me question
him look i don't like the guy i think
he's got weird weird views on the world
i don't trust him i think he's a bad
person i look at his history and how he
started my uh microsoft and how he he he
moved through silicon valley much like
steve jobs also not a good guy but the
problem i have with this like here is a
guy who did a thing it's like yo what's
happening in the world right now
involves thousands of people we can talk
about donald trump's role in 15 days to
slow the spread but i don't think trump
was a big player and exactly what was
going on i think he got swept up in it
we could talk about joe biden's attempt
at a vaccine man that we could struck
down and then everyone's like but but
but you know bill gates but biden's not
there biden is not a human being who's
pa who's not even consciously there
there's other people behind him there's
special interest behind them there's
major corporations i know
there's globally we can talk about how
pfizer
has been dumping money into these these
companies uh into the media outlets
sponsored by sponsored by getting
getting no why not ability contract why
shouldn't we talk about them they're
influenced players they're they're the
base players the issues and there's
players is that i want to talk about the
players
the koch brothers are doing this and
george soros is doing they are bill
gates is doing this
you want me to give you a list of the 2
000 billionaires who are all doing this
look i get it it's frustrating for me
because people talk about bill gates in
some superficial manner like did you
know that he gave money to the media
what does that mean tell me what that
means i know he owns influence the dude
has had influence for decades they all
do this one story does not say anything
about the fact that
one story after another story after
another story man literally trying to
control the weather it's his obsession
he i'm not he's he's making gmo
mosquitoes if you think this person no
i'm not yes you are no i'm not
absolutely not you can name it
you can name george soros and the da's
he's been funding this is why we're
frustrated and why shouldn't you
what frustrates frustrates me here is
you get a story from june 2021 where uh
barda which is a bio research lab in the
u.s i believe through hhs gets a
weaponized smallpox a drug uh approved i
believe was a proof i could be wrong
about this
bill gates comes out and says i'm
worried about weaponized smallpox and
all of a sudden the conspiracy realm
lights up saying bill gates is doing
whatever and it's like dude he read the
news that's not what we said i never
said anything about you you did i'm
saying the issue i take is yeah there's
other people that take it too far of
course and so the issue i take is like
i've just had so many conversations
about the obsession over bill gates yeah
i think it's a it's a red herring to go
after the individuals because like if
you have a corrupt king that's
terrorizing his subjects you want to
remove that king you're going to get
another king and he may or may not
terrorize what you want to do is disrupt
the monarchy and change the system so
that there is no possibility for you you
need to replace the puppets so the
puppets look all right
in the blue puppet yeah avoid that and
no no no no i want to get the puppet you
want to fix the system so that one guy
can't become a
trillionaire
maybe here's the problem
right now we have a culture and culture
is more powerful than politics and law
as i've mentioned numerous times the
easiest way to explain it is there's
wacky laws in massachusetts you know
they have a law from the 1600s you can't
put a pie in your window sill on sunday
afternoon because it attracts bears and
now no cop will enforce that
so when you get
a hundred million people and you're
standing before them and they say tell
us what's happening you say this bill
gates guy spent money in the press they
go what am i supposed to do with them i
wouldn't say that no stop or you say do
not let the government put their boot on
your neck do not let them mandate
medical procedures influence the culture
i have never never i i don't like i
don't like doing these bits where it's
like did you know person x did x there
or did y you have all of these youtubers
who make videos about people people
people people people people and then
regular people who are standing at ready
saying i want the world to be a better
place for my kids i want to make sure i
have my freedoms and my liberties what
should i do you should be met at bill
gates and they go okay i won't fight in
any meaningful way for principles i
won't focus on what's happening in my
community i won't vote locally i'll
complain about bill gates then those
people go out to rallies and they hold a
big sign saying bill gates and then when
regular people show up to go look at the
crazy people look at the crazy people no
so this is what frustrates me whenever
it comes to the vaccine stuff everyone's
like let's have a debate over science
and we're not scientists and i'm like
why
why when we can just say we're advocates
for freedom we are american citizens who
know the history of this country and the
founding fathers who said we demand
freedom and respect and tell the people
instead of trying to pretend to be a
scientist who's going to argue about
medical efficacy we can just say i
reject your attempts to mandate a
medical procedure on me the two are not
exclusive you could have both and i
don't just obsessively talk about bill
gates i talk about him i talk about all
the other very influential people who
are doing that but i also talk about
solutions i also talk about personal
responsibility i also talk about the
need for you to wake up from this
trauma-based mind control and psychosis
that people are going through by
watching the mainstream media by
watching what bill gates funds by
watching what all these other
individuals find out in order
no i don't think i do because if people
actually do find out the reality of the
true existence of this world which many
of them are right now many people are
waking up when people
see the true reality of it they start
understanding the players behind the
scenes here then they could start
implementing policies where they're not
victimized by these players and their
games that they play on the rest of the
population we don't get towards a
convention of states assuming that's
what we want we don't get towards a
populist uprising because a bunch of
people went outside complaining about
bill gates i'm not saying complaining
about bill gates i'm saying understand
the problem and be able to
diagnose it correctly without playing
their games of here's a puppet vote for
this puppet this puppet's going to make
things better
guy funding the da's yeah we do we are
not seeing parents rise up and revolt
because they found out about bill gates
we're seeing we're seeing their children
and their families being affected
they're seeing their culture be
destroyed and it's it's and who's so
common who's doing that who's
responsible
for for all who's doing all this bad
stuff it doesn't
matter it does i think it's a result of
the system if you have a technocracy
removing one technocrat another one will
fill the void so we want to figure out a
system that's a politician ian same with
not a text same with their politics you
remember one president of the upper
echelons because there is an inner
circle that inner circle deserves to be
addressed we have different approaches i
think it's important along with going
after the solutions along with
understanding the full problem that
we're seeing in front of us to be able
to fully just to be able to fully deal
with this problem you got to fully
understand it and you can't just be
looking at the consequences you can't
just be going after the side effects
okay and the challenge we have is that
none of this is relevant because what
matters is culture culture building
politics is down downstream from culture
and a bunch of people who have said i've
identified a source of the problem and i
believe it's bill gates are gonna are
going to convince no one and change
nothing the truth but you know what but
you know what people want a symbol for
their oppression so they isolate
an individual for a long time it was
george soros and still is now bill gates
is filling that role every single story
every quote every comment has brought up
and i'm just wondering like are we
having a debate about this one guy we
don't like are we going to talk about
how we're going to influence the culture
so that these la these laws can be the
culture is downstream from the
technology that's basically functioning
as a gatekeeping system allowing what
culture is seen where and then you got
to say who built that centralized
technology and bill did build some of it
but
a lot of people have built a lot of
central and are in the process of
building centralized uh tech technology
system i think allison mcdowell is
really a fascinating human being i was
well i would love to know
so like some of these solutions like i
agree with what you're saying when we
especially when we point at certain
people i want to know like what is the
actionable step so when you're talking
about solutions
i would love to hear some of what you
think would actually be solutions for
people in mass families your or whatever
like at home in the home solutions and
do any of them have to do with dmt yeah
dft is a personal decision that
individuals should do their own research
their own homework
yes of course so we all we all go
through it and when we dream every
single night that's something that
should be up to the individual
but again i think understanding exactly
what's going on is the first step
towards dealing with the problem
obviously we have a very sick society
obviously we have a very corrupted
society understanding how it's corrupted
who it's corrupted by and how we cannot
be corrupted by it i think is the first
step whether it's uh you know the school
the indoctrination centers whether it's
the medical centers that keep charging
people 30 for an aspirin that rob people
of their wealth and health whether it's
the banking system whether it's all the
systems that are thrown and shoved down
our throats every single day that are
scams ponzi schemes against the american
people we when we are victims to it when
we are blind to it we give all of our
power to these individuals and i'm
saying these individuals are doing all
this i think that's an essential part to
break it all down and to say hey you
know what maybe i won't vote with my
dollar at this particular business maybe
i won't put my child in an
indoctrination center maybe i will look
into homeschooling maybe i won't depend
on all my food from you know the the
amazon or a walmart maybe i'll start
looking into farming maybe i'll start
building a community of people that i
could actually have a support system
around me and i didn't think just
acknowledging like hey there's some big
bad people out there some of them are
sociopaths understanding that reality
and not blaming everything on on
generalized topics like culture culture
is absolutely important but you build
that culture from a sense of reality not
from a sense of i just want this let me
go get this this is why
you know the freedom might look this
i used to work for a bunch of
non-profits i used to fundraise for
green priests about for a month and a
half i worked for a couple a couple
really big national non-profits
and i was a nation's best fundraiser i
was able to walk up to a random person
on the street make them hand over their
credit card to me in 30 seconds this is
what the job is you've seen them on the
street they say hey come over here and
talk to me and i will tell you the one
thing that never convinces anybody is
blaming a person they don't know they're
confused by it how does that affect me
who is this guy what does he do what
does this mean bill gates has has bought
me in influence in the media he's
manipulative he has these weird ideas
and he's not a doctor and they say
that's weird what does he how does how
does what does he do i don't understand
in order to give someone enough
information to understand why bill gates
is a bad person and why george soros is
a bad person and why these other
billionaires because there are many and
many many of them is a bad person you'd
have to put them in a school for years
to really break down all this stuff and
so what you end up having is you have a
bunch of people who've been in this
world for a really really long time they
know and they can easily recall the
history of the you know how microsoft
came to be how they got their first
deals they went and they bought it the
arguments between steve jobs and bill
gates steve jobs the things he did they
were very very just dirty individuals
and i mean like
like
just willing to exploit and rip off and
and corrupt
and we know these things
but then there's a guy's a truck driver
and you go to him and you say all of
your problems stem from
bill gates is a billionaire who does
these things and he's going to be like
look guy i have no idea how that's going
to give me any information i need to get
my kids food but then we can bring it
back to their world we can speak to them
on their terms and things they
understand and say
hey
should you be forced to do x y or z by
your government and they'll say no it's
like this is the opening of the door
you say the things that directly affect
you that are causing you problems can be
solved if you wake up and start paying
attention but what we get a lot of is
george soros the left has their koch
brothers the left has their mercers and
i've been in these activist groups and
i've seen just how ineffective it is to
to say a word that means nothing to
somebody a name that means nothing to
somebody but think you're you're giving
some great revelation joe rogan just
pointed out to alex jones when he was on
the show on tuesday that alex has the
problem of knowing and so when he tries
explaining to people and he says really
like things that are so out there they
don't understand it actually makes them
push away from you you cannot walk up to
a person who's never experienced and who
doesn't understand the nitty-gritty of
what's going on immediately jump crank
up the dial to 11 and think they'll
listen to you we're not doing that we're
not jumping up to random people we're
having a talk show where we delve deep
into a complicated topics the reason
people listen to us is because it's an
honest real conversation that isn't
afraid just to be on the surface level
we go deep down and i think this is why
this podcast is so special because we
could do that and i disagree with your
characterization
we're not talking to random people on
the street here we're talking to an
informed public that is paying attention
and i don't think everything that
happens in this world is a coincidence i
do think there's bad people out there i
do believe there is going to be really
bad things that are going to continue to
continue to happen unless people realize
that these people are actually doing it
and i think that's also a part of the
solution as well as taking personal
responsibility for yourself as a human
being and that's something i preached
from the very beginning be informed
what's going on don't be a victim of
these people move away from them and
support systems and structures and
businesses that align with your
principles with your morality and what
you believe deep down in yourself when i
think of like this whole system and like
how we fix i think of it kind of a game
theory and military theory i think of
like band of brothers taking a bunker
when you have a target or when you're
focusing on like who did that like let's
say you're talking about bill gates or
whatever you don't want to like yell out
hey bill and like go directly at him
because that's then you become an easy
target you kind of want to to flank the
the target and like
confuse the target and like
i really and ultimately persuade that i
mean ultimately we're not at war with
each other we're we're on the same team
trying to help society we just have
different methods so you want to kind of
convince the target and
i i think what luke is doing is looking
through a telescope backwards because
when you start with the people and not
with the ideas people don't understand
what you're trying to say when you tell
them when you come up when you tell
people about this idea and you say
something like and i really think that
bill gates is a symptom of this they may
understand it better because that idea
affects them directly centralization
affects people who drive trucks it
affects people who work at small
businesses and this is something that
they will understand much better than
saying george soros is our enemy it
doesn't matter what george soros is
doing doing i'm just trying to drive a
truck and keep my family people want a
symbol
of of something that they they want a
symbol to represent what they believe
oppresses them or causes them problems
and harm
and for a lot of people it's very easy
to just name a person the thing about
bill gates he's a bad guy he's a pretty
pretty bad guy he has a lot of bad
things a lot of bad ideas he's in my
opinion a sociopath
but we're not talking about the other
thousand billionaires that do the exact
same thing
and this is the issue i take with it it
would be impossible for us to actually
go through the huge list of all of these
powerful global elites of old money and
new money of arrogance and ego of um ill
repute people who who are callous
utilitarians who believe in that some
some people can be sacrificed who are
willing to commit atrocities people like
fauci for instance i mean this guy is is
dark the the stuff he's been funding the
lies he said these are people who just
don't care and there are so many of them
but it can but it can change if people
are told very simply like simple ways to
improve their lives to give them
information about basic things that are
going on and you open the door and allow
them to walk through it you don't run up
to them jump drop kick them and smash
them through the window and try and push
them outside because they'll freak out
so when it comes to
you know like promoting a cause and
trying to convince people to say sign up
for a non-profit become a member
or something they've never heard of
the one thing i would always do when it
came to you know how do i convince
someone to want to save the forest you
have to make it relatable and start with
something they understand because in my
opinion it's disrespectful to demand
someone know something they've never
heard of
so if you if you approach it with
here's the guy here's the bad guy he's
the villain and then people like i said
go out with signs saying the villain
everyone else looks at that and says
that is meaningless i disagree with your
characterizations with linda and yours
as well because i think saying hey don't
talk about this don't talk about this
isn't going to help anything in the long
run and if you've looked at what i've
been talking about for a very long time
if you want to look for the person
that's responsible
for are your woes for all your problems
you have to look in the mirror and once
you look in the mirror you start
understanding the personal
responsibility that you have within
yourself to understand what's going on
and not fall for the traps i think it's
important to understand the traps as
much as it is the people who lay the
traps and i think we if we understand
how people lay the traps why they laid
traps what traps are out there i think
that's something that we should not be
afraid to talk about i think that's
something that intrigues people i think
that's what people want to know people
want to see about this
want to see all this different
information about this and it's not a
telescope where we're looking the
opposite way
i would say you're in a dark room just
bumping your head walking around not
knowing what's going on you're going to
continue bumping your head until you try
to shine some kind of light on it and on
the insects or whatever is hitting your
head so it stops hitting your head so
that's my perspective that's my point of
view personal responsibility is
something i have always preached that's
why i created we are change it's about
being the change that you want to see in
the world not just blaming somebody else
calling them the boogeyman i agree with
some elements and i even addressed this
before in previous videos where i said
hey we shouldn't maybe even be calling
these guys the elites because we're
giving them all of our power we
shouldn't be giving them all of our
power because we have the power and only
our ignorance fuels them and gives them
all of our power so i think waking up to
the really bad people it's not just you
know all these other billionaires
they're not creating gmo mosquitoes
they're not creating technology that's
going to be embedded microchipped in
people that's going to control their
fertility why are you pointing at me i'm
poisoning you
right right right there
there's different levels they're not
hanging out with things people like
jeffrey epstein and all these other
individuals there's the other level of
depravity of psychopath evil behavior
that deserves to be called out so so
real quick the the the release of the
gmo mosquitoes i was in florida right
mm-hmm
what was that
a company or a lab had to do that work
which means there has to be employees
there has to be people there has to be
research there has to be funding funding
probably came you know i assume you're
saying it came from bill gates can you
name the other people involved in that
project um i could probably i don't want
to talk out of my butt so i have to
research it and get you the particular
facts on it but when it comes to the
scientific community there's a thing
called the bill chill
that
freezes a lot of people in the
scientific community from even
criticizing bill gates on a lot of his
projects because of the large amounts of
investment that he has in this entire
industry through the bill and melinda
gates foundation how do you stop someone
from working for a company that would do
something like make genetically modified
mosquitoes to be released you put them
in a dark room for seven days oh my gosh
until they start producing and dodging
his dmt and they realize the error of
their ways i'm sorry i had to segue that
i i think i think in the past you know
um
certain uh you know jordan peterson
talked about enforced monogamy and it
triggered a bunch of people who thought
he meant like the police would come and
make women get married to like insults
or something but what he meant was uh i
could be doing this wrong but my
understanding is that society
as a whole culturally was like this is
what is normal and there are a lot of
things that are enforced not through law
but through culture and society that
people would not people would say like i
can't do that we used to have it um
we've lost it to a great deal because
i guess you could argue multiculturalism
in the in the definition used by the
right that you have a bunch of different
groups that don't view each other as
part of the community and so they don't
actually feel like they're committing a
wrong against someone that matters we
see this with activists we see with
police you know the the ante for people
would always say snitches get stitches
and so if somebody within like occupy
wall street for instance would commit a
serious crime they'd be like don't
report it to the police they just get
stitches basically saying we feel no
remorse and no harm and we feel no
remorse we regret nothing if we allow
this person who wronged us to go free or
to wrong someone to go free there was a
few people who were um
let's just say raped in occupy wall
street and the occupiers warned
everybody will beat you up if you tell
the cops this happened see when you have
a cohesive community and people have
scruples they would feel within their
heart like i can't do that because it's
just wrong to do that to somebody else
but when you have people willing to work
for these companies where they say
things like i don't care that other
people are being harmed by this you get
like we're talking about like the
banality of evil uh some some
commonplace thing where people are just
willing to do it so my view of a lot of
this is
if uh
if you tried bribing a cop what's the
likelihood you would take the bribe in
the united states right they're they're
unlikely the reason what state depends
what the bribe is but for real for the
most part it is relatively unlikely you
get pulled over the cop walks up and
says you were speeding and you say
officer here's a thousand bucks to make
it all go away josh the cop's going to
be a like i i even stepped out of the
car but he's going to be like you're
under arrest yeah that's that's scruples
even if he needed the money even if he
needed the money yeah because he's
probably on being recorded and
everything
it's five dollars in africa exactly now
there are some cops who would be like i
am desperate let's talk because people
get desperate or there's and there's
corrupt cops they're gonna be like i'll
take some free money now go to russia
in russia it's implied the cop pulls you
over you broke the law you say what do i
owe you and he goes you know give me 20
bucks i was talking to kim.com he
explained to me how he even bribed a cop
to pull his friend over so he'd win a
race because they're for sale
you see when you have a culture that
that believes in each other believes in
morality as a moral framework things
like what you're describing can't happen
how do we build that moral framework
back up we explain to people our ideals
we we explain to them very simple um you
know values and principles we explained
to them here's what's happening right
now you're being negatively impacted by
high gas prices okay well this is the
result of a large political system and
it has a lot to do with how you
participate in politics
it's very hard to vote your way out of
it to be completely honest but you know
i i grew up and i saw a lot of these
videos and i saw a lot of these uh you
know i've known about alex jones for a
really really long time and i always
felt like
none of this stuff has been particularly
effective in getting people to actually
build that culture where they'll say i
am unwilling to commit this act
instead where we have now is how michael
males described it most people are
willing to be
prefer safety over freedom so when they
come out and they say we are hereby
stripping you of all of your rights they
say okay
i'll use i'll give you a simple example
guns
i could come out here all day and say
mike bloomberg is the problem he's
trying to take away your guns
but to a regular person that's not an
argument to a regular person they're
sitting there saying someone broke into
my house and stole all my stuff and beat
my wife and then i say michael bloomberg
is the is the reason and they'll be like
i don't know what that has to do with or
i say
hey have you considered you know
purchasing a firearm to protect yourself
and then they say
you know i've never been a big fan i've
been worried and i've heard these things
let me give you some basic information
on gun culture and understanding so that
you can have something to protect
yourself so that you won't be victimized
again but hold on then this person goes
and buys a gun they experience gun
control for the first time they get
angry they say hey wait a minute it's my
constitutional right then they start
spreading those ideas around everybody
here's what affected me directly when i
when i was wronged
michael bloomberg spent hundreds of
millions of dollars trying to get guns
banned tom steyer as well but telling
people these names doesn't change the
culture doesn't inspire them to buy to
buy weapons to exercise their rights and
to protect their families why can't you
do both why do you have to have a
blinders at the cause of the problem
rather than just focus on those sessions
why can't you do all of that who says
because you're because the main critical
point that you have of me right now is
that as i bring up a lot of these other
people right so i bring up like the
bloomberg's in this scenario i think you
should build the culture and build and
talk about bloomberg i think you could
do both and they don't have to be
exclusive to each other i don't think
you need blinders and not talk about the
the root cause of the problem while of
course pushing in the culture which i
think is also absolutely important you
do want to map the system like you were
saying if you're in the dark room you
don't want to bump your head you need to
map it so you know what you need to
understand it but um and like what you
said earlier tim you don't want to put
make villains on a poster anyone's like
down with person x because what will
happen is all the other villains
eventually when it builds up to a point
will throw that guy under the bus and
then you'll get this sociological
cathartic
faux release
but the system hasn't changed
they just removed one of their own and i
think that's what happened to jeff
epstein in a lot of i think he was part
of a lot a big organization and they
threw him i i think they they threw him
under the bus yeah i gotta to a certain
degree yeah and i gotta say like you
know for the most part what i've seen is
actionable when it comes to conspiracies
and naming big names and stuff like that
what's actionable for most people
isn't something that's gonna do much for
their lives i think luke you are an
exception because
you're okay looking into the abyss and
looking for solutions as well
a lot of people when they hear that
stuff
they
they don't feel inspired to look big and
to have some kind of grandiose 30 000
foot view of what's happening they
really just want to protect their family
if you think about it now like
evolutionarily we would look out into
nature to see if there was something
hunting us and we would always do that
now people do that with news and they're
looking through
you know and i'm i'm generalizing here
but from the most part like you have the
the protectors watching news trying to
figure out am i safe am i in a safe
world we're not looking through the
trees trying to figure out if predators
are there anymore so it's it's ancient
um
architecture we're talking about so most
people with conspiracy it downgrades
their prefrontal cortex and they start
going back into the the hind brain they
start getting you know scared
unnecessarily it doesn't do anything for
them i think that's the majority of
people some people looking at the big
looking at the specific actors like you
i think it actually like in the in the
film divergent i think it actually turns
you on so you start realizing no i i
gotta look at the deepest and darkest so
we can start building back from there
it's it's really tricky though when it
comes to conspiracy i think over 90 of
it is fluff
much of it intentional fluff and then
only a little bit of it and i know you
had alex on and you were pulling up
articles and stuff like that and seeing
that yeah this this some of this stuff
really does pan out for most people
conspiracy does nothing good for them so
me i'm more of like an archetypal
conspiracy theorist i know there's some
shady [ __ ] going on i know that but when
it comes to really like pointing at
who's involved
i i'm not going to say that's a tool you
shouldn't pull out of the tool belt but
it's it's probably like a handgun it's
probably like a rifle you know what i
mean it's it's it's for select moments i
really believe because most people they
can't handle
what that means when you say did you
know x y and z they're trying to do this
to you and your family they don't know
what to do with that so so they shut
down i think
well i think it's it's it's confusing to
a lot of people to introduce foreign
concepts
to us you know i have to talk about how
when we do when i do new segments i try
to be careful to a certain degree
because you don't want to be esoteric
there are a lot of people who have on
the show and i talk to them and they're
like hey you know how do we get the
podcast bigger and i was just like just
keep in mind that a lot of people who
tune in might know something and be
concerned about something that's like in
the culture in the now in the know and
you can talk about the nitty gritty
details they don't understand so i
actually i just recorded something with
joe rogan i don't know when the episode
goes up but um there were a few points
where i was like if i want to make this
story quick it's going to be too
esoteric for the average person and
we'll have to actually break down the
terms the individuals involved so we
were talking a lot about the written
house trial
and naming the individuals who were
involved in all it's all the witnesses
and it's like who's that what does that
mean what is this so i i one one moment
was i mentioned a duty to retreat and he
says no no stop like you're glossing
over that what does that mean because
joe knows the average person is not
going to understand if i talk about this
as as an
i shouldn't say expert but as like
someone in the weeds
so the challenge is finding that balance
there are a group of people that
want to know that that don't like the
the powerful individuals who are poor
playing these games who are manipulating
and influential the issue i take for the
most part is i feel like you as i
mentioned you actually solve the problem
but there will always be powerful
individuals there was this stockbroker
guy and i can't remember exactly what
happened but he got called out and you
know it was i think it was during amc or
whatever it was doing gamestop and he
said you know the crazy thing is when i
got into this i was a little guy
fighting the establishment and today i
realized i'm the establishment and i
just didn't realize that happened so
there will come a point in time where uh
say like for this show for instance and
the money we spend people are going to
be livid furious outraged at what i'm
funding on foundation for instance
amazing we're trying to create uh i'll
give you a good example we're trying to
create software to make it so that no
one can ever be censored again but this
means really really bad people with
really awful ideas won't be able to be
censored you're going to get a bunch of
people being like tim poole has been
funding these programs to give evil
people platforms so they can never be
shut out of society and they're wrong
and they're violent they're angry and
they're evil and then they'll start
focusing on me because they'll come a
point where i gain too much influence or
power in some capacity sometimes evil
people take an uber you don't blame uber
for it
we're talking about different levels
though i mean this is like entry level
comparatively to like the 100 billion
level there's a big difference between
the two what i mean to say is just like
we need to inspire people to hold true
to principles and ideas that they
understand very easily um because when i
would do segments i'd often say it's not
fair of me to assume you guys have the
time to watch the news every day like i
do so if i watch the written house live
stream all day just glued to it for the
court trial the average person can't do
that because they have jobs and they
have work so they say i want to turn on
someone i trust who's going to you know
give me what i believe to be
the correct information and will do
their best and so i often try to say i
will do my best to give you information
because i know you don't have the time
to do it that is not to say i think
anyone is is stupid no i think
that people are looking for a service we
provided and i have to respect the fact
that
they don't have the time
to know everything dude i was thinking
of your metaphor of looking through the
forces but there's a counter argument to
make this to make here because i don't
think we should be kind of talking down
or talking to people like children i
think there are some advanced level
people that do want to hear advanced
level stuff and sometimes entertaining
that i i think is good but i understand
you kind of lose people by going too far
down in the rabbit hole but i think some
of some of the people do need to go down
there just to say hey it's pretty
interesting down here uh you may want to
know what's going on it's kind of like
if you're you guys are like scouts you
know you're looking like your metaphor
looking in the woods for danger you're
looking at the news and you're looking
through it's like you're both seeing the
enemy army coming and tim is like we're
being flanked from the left by cavalry
the archers are behind and watch out for
the spearmen in the right and luke's
like yeah but you see the king that's
not actually the king the king's the guy
next to him that guy with the armor is
not the king princess amidala was
actually so don't send all your forces
to fight and go after this king because
it's a fake king and it's a fake
illusion you're going to waste all your
time and energy while the real bad guy
gets away and then sets up more horrible
traps and more armies against you but
here's my thank you i'll put it this way
i'll i'll counter point you've got
the the the feudal lords you know uh
palace or whatever and all of the
subjects are standing around and all the
guards are standing there and they're
all bowing
and then you go up and say you know that
you know the lord is the problem and and
look at all the bad things he's doing
or you just go to all the people and say
hey let's all come together and
ignore that do this thing i'm not saying
ignore bill gates or anything they're
doing what i mean to say is if the
confidence is broken by regular people
and they just do their thing and believe
in their values and principles and focus
on on that it's a grassroots effort then
all of a sudden the chain breaks and
these powerful individuals have no
ability to influence the point i was
making is with like the lab in florida
wherever they made these mosquitoes
because they did this i don't know when
they did this but there's this big
mosquito release there just a couple
months ago in key west florida they
released it yep let me give you let me
give you a better story uh cassandra
fairbanks wrote about this
there's a um fouchy
the niaid fundamental
maximum pain research
on on primates and primates are
intelligent i mean this is like this is
brutal stuff
who is the person who's willing to
conduct this painful research
maximum pain
these people
shouldn't should the the ideas they have
and the things they're willing to do
shouldn't exist in my opinion the people
who who are raised in this world who
come to a point where they say i have no
qualms inflicting maximum pain on
primates to see what happens at a
certain point we need to be like
how did you get to that point because
it's not bill gates who made him do that
now certainly money is an influencer but
how do we make sure the moral framework
and i'm gonna be i'm gonna be uh maybe
offensive to all the atheists and
secularists i believe that as we begin
losing the the christian moral framework
you end up with people who don't believe
in any kind of moral framework and
that's we get from wokeness you get
people who believe that there there is
no truth but power these are the kind of
people that you know you eventually see
in world war ii era japan and you end up
with the the nazi party the people who
are willing to commit atrocities against
others because they don't feel that they
have there's no remorse
if the values are instilled in an
individual to respect others to hold a
certain moral framework and i believe we
were all raised in a christian moral
framework i'm not saying the religion
i'm not religious but that moral
framework has in it the fifth amendment
the sixth amendment yes all of these
things you end up with people who would
sit there and they'll say we'll pay you
a million dollars to torture these
monkeys they'll be like i will never do
that and then you don't have to worry
about these horrifying things someone
would say hey we want you to genetically
engineer mosquitoes that are going to go
around whoa whoa whoa that's too much
for me i'm not going to do that when
you're talking about values i think
you're you're nailing it on the head and
um narrative like you know one thing
that that holds a country or a tribe or
whatever together is a collective myth
it holds certain values in it and we
have that in our own way
um and that's one thing that's kind of
breaking down now
is our collective myth and what i feel
really causes for that breakdown is
dividing not just the family structure
but dividing us from one another and
putting an intercessor some kind of
technological intercessor and i think
the solution
um we talked about this when joe rogan
was just on recently he said you know
like what what compelled kyle
rittenhouse to go there and he said
anarchy and chaos in the streets and i
like i know that like the word anarchy
actually has a little bit deeper meaning
to that which i won't go super into but
like it's more about localism as well
like locally controlling certain things
and and connecting with one another what
happens when you go local i'm not saying
this is the answer
but when you have more of a community a
real community you live your values with
one another you don't have a piece of
technology in between you and like oh no
i did i couldn't hear those last five
words that you just said because the
algorithm blocked it you know community
real
connectedness i think that's something
that um is going to uphold our values
because i do think that it's the erosion
of our values that we're seeing a lot
right now to be a little obnoxious like
like here here we have here we have a
bill gates and here we have his mini
meet dr fauci who's been working and
collaborating collaborating with him
almost every step of the way since
covert started but that's that's a
separate topic the community building is
absolutely key it's absolutely essential
because if you don't have a strong group
if you don't have a family if you don't
have core values you of course will be
picked apart you of course will be
manipulated you of course will be thrown
into a situation where you become your
very own worst enemy and you will be
susceptible to these traps these games
that i've been talking about before and
and i think a lot of people have been i
think a lot of people are suffering a
lot of people are not in a good state
and i think that's only going to
continue not when we just change the
culture but when we address the root
cause of everything that's happening
here and we addressed the importance of
personal responsibility self-education
and making yourself aware of not only
the things outside of you the important
people controlling pushing things but
also the things inside of you and the
things that you can make a big
difference in when it comes to your own
personal choices and decisions you make
in your life sometimes it's as simple as
meditating for 10 minutes sitting in a
room examining your life and deciding
where you wanted to go as a human being
you know you know it's frustrating
i
despised bill gates way before it was
cool
well you know because uh because i knew
a lot about computers and stuff growing
up and there's there's a film called the
pirates of silicon valley in the film
yeah and i'm like these guys are just
bad people i remember during occupy wall
street they made a shrine for steve jobs
when he passed yeah and i was like what
is wrong with you these people are all
authoritarian but i'll just really
simplify the point i was trying to make
is
i don't feel like
talking about bill gates
is is solution oriented i understand why
people don't like him i understand he
does bad things and i think it's
important that people know why he's a
bad dude and the bad things he does i
especially think it's important to point
out that joe rogan can give an opin give
his opinion and the media just attacks
him and then bill gates does and they
cheer for him when
neither are doctors
i would say he gets away with this
because he has the cover because he has
no one paying attention to him he cares
what the public thinks about him that's
why he buys the best pr staff to hide
all of his jeffrey epstein connections
which were far more extensive if people
found out about exactly what he was
going on he wouldn't be able to get away
with more than half of the stuff that
he's already getting away with so he
hides under the cover of darkness and i
think that's why shining a light on him
would show you a big room with him
slapping you upside the head and once
you see someone slapping you upside the
head you know exactly what's going on
and you could actually deal with that
particular problem here's so that's my
perspective my point of view from this
entire kind of saga it might be wrong i
can admit if i'm wrong sometimes i might
be wrong so the channel might be
delusional i might be too much down the
rabbit hole i could admit that as well
so the challenge i see is it's not just
bill gates it's not just george soros
i mean uh vladimir putin what's they
they some what is it worth 700 billion
they argue like secret money hidden he's
got like the biggest house in the world
i don't know if he's actually worth
whatever that's maybe it's 70 billion i
don't know maybe i was wrong no no i'm
thinking 700 because uh
elon musk has almost 300 billion in
value yeah so they say 94 for bill gates
they say that vladimir putin is like
secret money he doesn't want to know
about i certainly don't believe all the
stupid russia get garbage nonsense but
you look at all of these countries and
they're all playing their influence
games so
yeah bill gates is one of the worst
bloomberg is one of the worst steyer is
one of the worst these people are
funneling money and doing a ton of
really bad stuff but my view of it is
kind of like imagine your house is on
fire
and there's big raging flames and so
you're like the first thing we have to
do is go to the electrical socket in the
basement where the fire started and tell
everyone that's where the fire started
that's not my attitude is kind of like
why don't we get everybody to put the
greater fire out and then we go to the
source of the fire and disable it like
turn the power off or something like
that or you know you you could try and
find a way to shut the power off first
but
you know where the fire is starting from
is it's a fair point to say
that i think there's arguments for both
both our both our sides on this one one
could be that if there is a leak in a
ship and the water is flooding up the
ship and you say we must bail the water
you're not stopping the fact the water
is still filling up
yeah right so
luke's point it's like everyone find the
hole first and then
luke's point is hey there's a crazy guy
putting more holes in the boat right now
there's a crazy guy adding more fuel to
the fire right now and it's going to get
really out of hand unless we stop this
one guy who started the fire and making
the fire that much worse right now as
we're speaking i'd like to point out
that there is another kingdom that is
paying people to come put holes in our
boat so let's see if we can fix that
it's super interesting though because
even lydia's back there and she's got
her own like ways of viewing it for me
this is the community this is just a
microcosm of the community
it takes all kinds somebody was just on
aubrey marcus's podcast it was a rabbi
mordecai i think and he was saying like
you know i i have no problem with
conspiracy theorists because i don't
invest myself in what they believe i
think back who were they in the tribe
who do you want the paranoid always
vigilant person in the tribe to be true
probably the lookout right you know and
they are valuable in that way and part
of what we're talking about with values
is
we don't have to like
pretend like people in our community
don't get on our nerves and don't
trigger us in some ways but the bottom
line is if we can't see any value in
what's happening in front of us then
we're missing some kind of lesson or
gift in it which is why you know it's
it's hard with what's going on in the
country right now but i'm really taking
a look at it when i when i look at the
the conspiratorial lens of what's
happening in the world right now i'm
more curious and my ideas are way out
there like first contact happened
thousands of years ago we just don't
know what we're looking at technology is
part of it you know i won't even go into
explaining it but what i'm saying by
that
is
i really think that reality is weirder
than most any of us can put into words
so the best thing we can do is find some
kind of harmony together whatever that
actually looks like some kind of harmony
together and that does not happen
without community coming together under
some premise under some story let's go
to super chats yes
i will also say just for this show right
ian and i argue and we have very
different ideas luke and i just argue
with very different ideas i think that's
why like
i think a goal of the show is maybe we
get a little too heated maybe maybe i
should have been more chill about it so
oh it's fine i want more
more passion more fire let's get it all
out i mean we these are important
conversations that we gotta get through
somehow and there's no other way but to
kind of go at it we could be fake to
each other we could pretend to believe
like we're somebody like we're not i'm
sick of that bull crap i'm sick of
people talking down to each other and
pretending that they're somebody that
they're not this is my point of view
this is yours we disagree let's go at it
let's not be let's not play patty cake
and pretend all right
that has to be wrong and that's what i'm
saying about you know what i go for um i
i i lost a lot of subscribers after the
election of donald trump and i and i
said i don't think the fraud narrative
is correct i think it was the shadow
campaign narrative i think they changed
the rules and i'm not gonna sit here and
just pretend i believe something hoping
my views go up that's not what i do uh
and if i get angry maybe i shouldn't but
you know if we have an argument i think
it's a good thing and then everyone in
the comments is allowed to tell me i'm
wrong and and argue back and that's why
i think this show is good i would advise
reviewing the tape to the point where
you think you might have been overboard
and just see because when you see
yourself you'd be like yes i was or no i
wasn't it's okay to have natural
emotional reactions if you're angry
you're angry let it out it's also if you
hide it and try to pretend like it's not
there it festers and builds up and
explodes in another area of your life so
it's important to express yourself and
assert yourself as a human being and and
and not play these bull crap social
rules that are just made up and yeah
just are nonsensical pretending i mean
there's there's you know being
respectful and stuff like that and
sometimes people get angry but i really
there are a lot of shows there are a lot
of commentators
that can't you know there's a lot of
people on the right that when when a
narrative emerges i see them jump right
on with whatever narrative makes the
most sense uh the example today when
when the judge said this nbc reporter
and this you know other person producer
tons of people immediately said this
producer did it and my response was for
all we know it was antifa
driving trying to track the jury down
and then just lied and said they were up
the press because we've seen that happen
before yeah i think it's you know we got
to be very careful not to immediately
just jump on bandwagons or just do it
for tribal reasons but
there are some people with big channels
with powerful followings that would
absolutely just say whatever they think
people want to hear if it gets them more
and more viewers but i'll tell you this
when i came out and argued with luke
a bunch of people left well you know
what look you're free to leave if you
don't like it but i'm not gonna sit here
and just pretend my feelings are
something else in hopes that people stay
right you probably evoked something
inside them
that they weren't ready to handle and
that's important to have on a show you
know because a lot of people are waiting
they're waiting well you know the thing
is is like either one of you might be
more right than the other but i think
the underlying important factor is that
you had the conversation so the greater
community could hear two very valid
points right and that helps refine their
their blade of discernment yeah i think
like i think this is far more important
than just covering news i think it's far
more important than just covering this
happened in the news today no we need to
get passionate we need to get involved
and we need to express our ideas in a
non-scripted way that truly tell the
audience who we really are because like
there's there's there's nothing uh
narrated here there's nothing uh
programmed here it's us having a normal
reaction in a normal conversation
without any of these kind of paradigms
that all these other mainstream media
family-friendly show
i can't say what i want to say but all
these other mainstream media hypocrites
live by we don't live by that by that
role set we live by a rule set where
this is what's on my mind it's going to
get out i don't care who it hurts or
offense super chats see what you guys
have to say smash that like button if
you still like the show of course you do
thanks so much for being for for
watching everybody and supporting our
work let's see what we got here oh man
youtube has started deleting super chats
what you know
youtube if when you get too many they
start purging the back end and that's
really i usually it happens only when we
get like a ridiculous amount of super
chats i didn't think we got that many so
all right sorry man all right so we got
z michael he says the source of that
footage is a uh front with a glowing
neon sign who air dropped the file
anonymously to the police sounds like
people who live in parallel i'm not i'm
not sure what that means interesting
so it was an anonymous
drop of
okay interesting i don't know
so we we we do have this story we're
going to talk about this a member
segment this is crazy um we were gonna
talk about it but i think we got bit
philosophical um roberto laura
says tim 800 okay guardsmen are not vast
this is insane i want to joke and say
that if the pentagon orders to remove
those who choose to comply with the
pentagon just created 800 uh kyles a
dark winter is coming i think the
pentagon actually said you will not be
in compliance with the national guard
and thus you will just be a state
militia oh okay
yeah that's crazy your terms are
acceptable but we're gonna get into that
too because we got some crazy uh data
coming out of the uk that um we're going
to talk about in the members-only
segment so go to timcast.com sign up
that'll be coming up around 11 or so p.m
let's read some more super chats
all right let's see
amanda what is that
dilts it's harder to rake because we
have smaller monitors here well actually
i could probably just look up actually
that's way with the bigger tv what am i
doing
all right amanda diltz says hernandez
video leading up rosenbaum shows
rosenbaum chasing rittenhouse drops
extinguisher and runs
through lot not once pointing on anybody
not only that something came out where
uh the jury said can we get the video of
written house putting down the fire
extinguisher and i think it was it might
have been viva fry said this that's the
language of the prosecution which is
indicative of the perspective of the
jurors
yeah because the defense did not say he
put down a fire extinguisher i think
they said dropped
so one in one instance dropping it means
he's running and he drops it and the
other end since he stops puts it down
aims a weapon
yup
all right
i don't know
rich legey says do you think the
prosecution will be charged or is
nothing going to happen again
man i hate to say it but i think
nothing's going to happen right like the
judge might be a while but if the judge
puts the prosecutor on the stand i would
i'd be so happy cool i've never seen
anything like this it's an eclipse
tonight so i'm ready for anything yes
yes is it a total eclipse i don't know
it's a partial it's the longest partial
lunar eclipse i don't know longest in
what period i don't know it's not on
it's not on the news the internet
the economy said should protesting near
a courthouse be illegal because it
affects jurors yes how can we keep
jurors safe i'm loving tim cast irl van
life edition i don't i don't think so i
think we have a right to express
ourselves especially in front of
government institutions
but that does mean that bad people will
do bad things and it's going to freak
the jury out and then you end up with
you know these bad cases the the greater
issue is is the culture as it is the
right is unwilling to engage in violence
the way the left is so the jurors know
the fear is not a acquittal the fear i'm
sorry the fear is not conviction it's
acquittal
if the jurors convict they know the
right will grumble if they acquit they
know they'll be threatened with their
lives because the left is extreme
violent and protected by the media and
the institutions and the establishment
so mind-bending how people can
coordinate and now in the last 20 years
since social media has basically been
invented and how how culture can be so
rapidly formed and dissolved and altered
by like a meme
like and then that controls
the politics of the world
in
like a a million people like how people
can prote be like hey tomorrow be at
this place at this time and a hundred
million people or a million people or
ten thousand people is like what the
how do we how do we protect jurors in
this world how how do we it's a mass
mobilization is a crazy thing the
founding fathers did not have to deal
with yeah
this one's a really important one uh
spidge bandersnatch says
tim
quote no reason to give them the benefit
benefit of the doubt what happened to
hanlon's razor ah i will tell you
hanlon's razor of course is never a
tribute to malice that which can be
explained incompetence my favorite um
however in this instance i cited i think
three examples of msnbc manipulating the
news
so then when you find out an msm msnbc
employee was tracking the jury van
and we know the judge already said this
can't happen it won't happen again
there's no attribute to incompetence
there that's
you're you then you're just you know
being a fool
and then as it pertains to the
prosecution they committed several grave
constitutional violations
so at that point we stopped giving them
the benefit out and assuming they're
just bad at their job we say nah you've
done it to me for me one shame on you
for me twice shame on me for me three
times you're not gonna fool me a third
time yeah
yeah
all right what do we got james nelson
says that video appeared friday right
before prosecutors
close uh close from an anonymous person
the crop compressed screams manufactured
evidence hail mary i agree and it just
so happens that krause has two programs
on his computer to do such a thing
and they're very specific programs if he
had adobe premiere i wouldn't have
better than i now have been like ah it's
premiere man it's like basic editing
software but he has like the cropping
and the compression software
specifically was the footage on fox
like actually
so anyone could have could have snagged
it off of the tv and then
his logo anonymous is kind of weird like
anybody could have done that i should
have send in evidence because it
probably would have appeared in trial i
mean that's how much oversight
yeah
brandon taylor says the defense's tech
lady said the lower resolution version
was created 21 minutes and 19 seconds
after the larger file they received was
created
so i just don't see a reality in which
the defense is like we're given two
files anonymously i'll send only one
because that would imply that they were
supposed to send both the prosecution
the pro right prosecution the
prosecution if they got two video files
would send both of them yes
definitely they didn't absolutely they
sent one with a different name that was
compressed so people are like if he sent
it over i uh iphone email it would
compress it but it wouldn't change the
name right
no yeah
there's not enough transparency here
yeah something is crazy here we go this
is good tony
uh nalogen says handbrake is an activity
log file in ghb directory that recorded
the file names of the source output file
and timestamps
under oath
subpoena seize the laptop yes but you
know what they're not going to do it
right and you know why because
doesn't know
because because the judge had a secret
meeting with bill gates and george
the judge said i don't understand he's
in his 70s yeah and the defense doesn't
know either yo why isn't defense like
watching these shows it's not just me
like rocato law went over this stuff
they've had massive live streams about
this
it's it's weird when when younger people
commenting on it know far more and
probably could have done a better job i
mean that's that's that's a big stretch
but i mean it really does seem like
there was there was
a lot of blacks
decision making going on how old were
the founding fathers like 28 28 26 30.
it was it was a while they were 70 they
weren't 78 years old though some i think
ben franklin was the oldest yeah well
one of the oldest yeah he was like in
his 50s right or something i don't know
i think so yeah
this is this is interesting andy f says
kraus claimed the detective sent him two
versions and the second version was
messed up he gave some reason detective
did it but i can't remember what it was
so
if the file was created 21 minutes after
the video they got then the detective
created both there's no scenario in
which it makes sense that an anonymous
source
sent
two files to the detective created
within 21 minutes of each other and then
the detectives sent both
one was messed up and then prosecution
just failed to deliver the high-res
version for any reason
none of this adds up
let's just let's just play devil's
advocate
kraus got two versions well then he
withheld evidence because he should have
sent both yeah that alone is i mean the
evidence has to be recalled i would
imagine
and he didn't so if that's the case
mistrial with prejudice yeah
it's not i i i you also there's levels
of ineptitude if you're looking for like
malice and ineptitude you have to
think like
what kind of an attorney is this and
would he not have thought of sending
both of them like how much ineptitude do
you have to go to
before you start realizing some of it is
is mal intent i'm gonna make a
prediction
jn says possibility of verdict coming on
friday so on the weekend things people
go off media cookies could be here's my
prediction tomorrow mistrial with
prejudice okay okay place your butts you
know why
that will create the maximum impact on
the riots the judge has to know though
waiting till friday
the judge said last week he didn't want
to do it go another week he wanted to
start a new trial on monday and he's
like why don't we do closing on friday
and they were like no we should do
closing on monday and i think both the
state and the defense were like yo if we
we should not but uh that would have
only triggered deliberations
um on monday i suppose but so maybe that
wasn't a factor
they waited till friday
is the judge going to want to carry on
or is he going to say it's been three
days if the jury is hung then we'll make
a decision on mistrial if he declares a
mistrial there may be some riots
probably not if he declares a mistrial
with prejudice which he has very good
reason to do they will light that city
up poor kenosha
yeah but poor everywhere else it's not
just gonna be kenosha you're right new
york city los angeles washington dc
chicago so what are so i'll tell you
this we got the mobile rv here the the
studio
is the crew going to be able to drive it
back if riots erupt over the weekend
hopefully probably it's texas to the
east coast they're not really driving
through any big crazy cities or anything
like that but uh miss trout with
prejudice i think if the judge says
mithril miss trout with prejudice i
think we may actually get george floyd
level riots wow again i'm just saying i
think it's possible i'm not saying it's
definitive and the reason is just
it would send a message to the left
that the judge
is everything they feared
and the and he knows written house is
guilty but he's gonna let him go and
that's gonna be their narrative and
they're gonna be like it's worse it's
worse than we realized it is the system
is so corrupt they will let them walk
free and then they'll be like
shut it down
that'll be the narrative that's right
i'd like to see that personally i don't
know if i can bet on it but
it seems like that's what has happened
is a mistrial should be called with
prejudice yeah like immediately too i
think yeah yeah it should have been done
first thing this week
over the the the the if they filed in
the 15th the judge knew the evidence was
not delivered he knew they're
deliberating on tampered evidence that's
crazy to me so the judge has to be ready
for a mistrust prejudice do it on a
tuesday yeah middle of the week on a
friday it's colder outside i guess yeah
that's true but l.a
yeah what's the weather this weekend
that has something to do with it
hopefully not little tails farms i say
tim jackman just said on telegram
that kyle's defense lawyer says he
believes it's a six six deadlock with a
jury just just now
i've seen that how would they know that
by eyeballing the jury when they're
sitting there i don't know that's a good
point how would the defense know exactly
the side source i don't know oh it could
be based on the uh the memos coming out
asking judge he's looking at the memo
yeah a lot of people pointed this out
all right ryona uh ryonantaka says
you're right tim those programs are for
specific purposes no reason to have them
otherwise they're playing to the judge's
tech ignorance praying he sees through
it and nukes them for it disgusting
there is an argument they want a
mistrial but without prejudice or
if binger really is the the cult member
ideologue some people have accused him
of being he purposely wants to sabotage
trigger a mistrial with prejudice to
make now they should make a movie about
that
change the names i've wondered whether
it was like intentionally stupid like
you know what the way he was going about
it seemed intentionally stupid and i
almost wondered
what's the angle of of the judge to
what did he say like i don't believe you
i don't believe you're acting in good
faith
but i'm gonna allow it is basically you
know what happened so i mean he he's
probably
i hope he's a little bit more hip and
he's letting something play out
was it in the art of wars that when your
enemies making a mistake
don't interrupt them i'm hoping that's
it yeah i hope so so uh
slenzer says
mistral without prejudice is bad for
defense it's like taking off your shoes
at tsa doesn't protect you from the next
bad uh for the next thing bad actors do
but
this will dramatically alter their use
of the video evidence and the drone
stuff it'll call everything crafted into
question if there's a mistrial without
prejudice and then
they still investigate what krause did
it could result in just charges not
being refiled for political reasons and
practical reasons
we have this other one this is from chet
chisholm he says barnes mentioned that
if it's a mistrial then that means they
may be trying to run kyle's funds down
to zero so he can't defend adequately i
do not believe that's correct
because the prosecution knows that kyle
rittenhouse is not just funded by
himself
this is the biggest it's a high profile
trial and if they did that
and the defense team for rittenhouse
came out made a video and said we need
your support they would raise two
million bucks in 10 minutes yeah it's
not an issue of funding
um and maybe it may be
but rittenhouse
his team they will have the support of
the people because even the progressives
have started acknowledging that it
looked like self-defense
they're like maybe i were wrong about
this and we were wrong about that you're
going to get too many people being like
i will give you 50 bucks and then he's
going to have all the funds for and in
fact this may result in a bigger defense
team yeah i mean they should have andrew
branca advising he should no joke yeah
and i was actually actually surprised
they didn't yeah i thought they were
going to
i don't know were they yeah i thought
they were
he's he's the law of self-defense guy
without him on the show yes excellent
commentary he he just has such great
insight he experts yeah he writes for
legal insurrection you guys definitely
want to check him out when it comes to
cases like this he just
when i read a bunch of news articles and
i get a bunch of words and i'm like
that's interesting when i read his he
like breaks down like the elements of
self-defense and goes through the
details and i'm like that's just a
better analysis you know great yeah but
i also like rocata law's streams all the
lawyers too because
you know then you're hearing from a lot
of different people and there's a bit of
you know here's this here's that i
wonder if like the defense can just get
like a panel from raqueta to like advise
in the background because then they'd
win it'd be like every every legal point
every precedent why wasn't that done i
mean like i'm gonna say it one more time
it's a high profile case they're booming
shouldn't that be the norm they're
boomers they don't know what they're
doing i hope that's
i don't know i don't know if that's the
case their third eye is calcified that's
right yeah i do so much i need a dark
room
i hear you did a movie about that yeah
so now we're getting to the super chats
where everyone was spamming luke is
right tim shut up luke is 100 correct
listen to him
let's speak the truth
let's see luke is right tim is scared
he's right
tim prefer here's one george cruz as tim
prefers showing facts supporters claims
we know gates controls but show proof of
his corruption devil's advocate
see devil's advocate that's me you're
advocating for me what is this devil's
advocate
uh carter strassen has tim getting
ratioed in chat i know you're all seeing
it even tim
tim you're cranky lack of sleep you're
being a bit of a richard to luke chill
out i will be fair and i'll say this
we did that really really big show on
tuesday and i'm like you know sorting
through all that i had to wake up super
early so i could get my work done so i
could go on rogan so i did an hour and
uh an hour and 40 an hour and 20 minutes
in the morning
two three hours with rogan and then
three hours at night and then i wake up
again to do the same thing then do an
hour with jones and then do another
three hours at night and then i gotta
wake up and again tomorrow so truth be
told i'm probably very drained
excuses yeah
we all worked excuses that was yesterday
tim we all work non-stop i don't know mr
vinton says lucas spent too much time
with alex jones
i don't think we've seen each other like
for the first time in like 10 years i
love it
last year when he came and woke me up in
my rv oh yeah and this is the second
time seeing him
in like 10 years
in very short instances if you keep it
up your voice is going to start sounding
like this and now now and now to be fair
i was actually just reading all of the
ones that were pro-luke but there are
some that were pro-tim um pagan
libertarian milady says you won't be
able to wake people up like that luke
don't cast pearls before before swine no
no no ish sherlock i know the but we got
to talk about solutions and them that's
all camel of the mojave says luke the
average person is not going to wake up
they aren't listening build a strong
community tell the government f off and
the people around you know free stuff
the elites are the people
chosen by the lazy common folk well you
can't be too nihilistic you can't be too
blackpill then just think everyone's uh
lazy and everyone's stupid that's the
thinking of the elites that's the that's
the thinking that the elites want you to
have the common man wants the best for
him and his family or her and her family
and i i think if we could just
understand that most people are good uh
deep down they're not psychopathic
people who hang out with jeffrey epstein
and do unspeakable things to children in
the name of some kind of weird
multi-dimensional religion luke and i
were in korea
and we did political compass tests and i
was center-left and he was like a mirror
image like we were like inversions like
right in the middle libertarian center
left center right oh cool and that's a
good example of what it is like i think
we're actually both right but kind of
not
seeing exactly what it is and i got
frustrated and you get intense
reverberations and then the kasmir
effect
i think that's what causes gravity
there's also the danger of like type
casting all people and saying that's not
the way to do it
that's not the way to do it yeah
absolutely that's the reason why you
know like stuart copeland and sting they
they hated one another and sting wanted
a different kind of drum sound and
stewart said no and you got police
coming out of it we we need some of that
you know what we can just do it's very
simple start a band bill gate sucks
that's the name of the band that's it
wait wait wait wait wait it's not just
about me and luke that's unfair we got a
super chat here from david tracy says
ian is completely right oh a new king
solves nothing a magna carta that makes
the king irrelevant solves plenty of
problems at least for a while
so you know what there's more than
enough of everyone here being right and
we all get participation trophies
john boyle says bill gates is evil but i
don't think he has he has this master
plan to change the fabric of america and
if there is this plan for the great
reset you think we would have any idea
who the who developed this in genius
plan there is a plan i think him schwab
the davos group um
like you you guys you got really got to
take a look at what goes on in davos for
the
economic forum it's not just the world
economic forum there's this big
peripheral institution around it all
these people show up setting up pop-ups
boutiques all promoting much of the
exact same ideas so you have this is
crazy like and i went to davos during
the world economic forum i couldn't get
into the actual thing i was in the
pop-ups but you actually have like on a
mountain basically at the top all of the
global elites being like
here are the issues of the world and
when you talk it's the world economic
forum and then outside you have like
the nobles who are all like the kings
are all correct and let's bask and
they're walking around and you've got
high ranking you know uh politicians and
the family members and all that stuff
all laughing and you know cheersing and
drinking you know beer outside of the
palace
and then in far far away where the
actual peasants are tilling the fields
they have no idea what's going on
they're walled out i i guess my point
there is just that it's not just the the
uh the royalty it's the nobility that
that you know shuffles around underneath
and and then opens their mouths as the
refuse pours from the palace the court
the king's court that lives within the
the castle on the castle grounds
also everything they talk about makes
some sense in the in the futuristic tech
you know technological world that we're
living in they're also talking about you
know the last thing that i saw from them
is they're talking about reshaping food
systems um you know from farm to lab as
well but basically using science and
data to revolutionize whole food systems
and to homogenize it so instead of
having like individual you know groups
being able to feed individual areas
every one across the board if this goes
through will be run by a singular system
now that just seems like common sense in
a world that does want some kind of
global top-down
rule i think we're moving into
technocracy that's that's my with food
that's dangerous to uniform food because
if like a a virus or a bacteria emerges
that destroys a certain type of
food or a fungus or something and then
we've all we've created our entire
system based on like a specific kind of
potato that could be very dangerous and
they're talking about land use mainly
they're talking about how do we use land
you know will they get to the point
where they're like let's take imminent
domain to a global level and talk about
how are we going to feed by 2050 10
billion people which is their
projections so they're already in the
long game thinking of 2050. i'll give
luke mentioned this but we have a super
chat too uncle sam says my view on who
to blame look in the mirror every one of
us has a part in this luke is right vote
with your money that means giving up
conveniences it won't change until we
ourselves change we have more power than
we know that's correct uh v for vendetta
you know uh if you're looking for the
guilty party there is and some are more
guilty than others you need only look
into the mirror i know why you did it
it's a great it's well written it's
amazing but yeah it's regular people and
that's why you know my view is very much
like
change has many it's grassroots and it's
probably because i come from you know a
more like lefty libertarian perspective
where it's like get as many of the of
the working-class little people to share
your idea and then it affects the
greater system above you know what i
mean but but i think you know i think i
think we both made our points and we're
both like probably in agreement with
each other just kind of like slightly on
the other side
let's see monkey wang says alex jones
explains the bill gates situation better
than luke and that's scary
well jones has been talking about for a
long time
well well going on you know i was on uh
info wars with jones
and uh he would say things that sounded
outlandish to me and i'd be like i don't
know about that because it's proven it's
confirmed it's declassified now but okay
and then he's like anyway moving on it's
like i don't i can't really say anything
something i don't know it sounds like
alex needs a jamie no no no like his
show is very in the weeds you know what
i mean and for me to go on and hear
these things for the first time that
i've never fact checked or looked into
his audience all knows oh i'm looking
i'm gonna watch that that's
gonna be awesome
is that up already
i think so yes i think it goes out live
doesn't it yeah i thought it streamed
though i don't know he gets a ridiculous
amount of traffic people don't realize
this they thought they they thought they
obliterated it like they thought they
banned him they cancelled him and then i
went and checked out banda dot video and
he's like millions of views and i was
like wow you know
he was big before social media
and they and he got way too he got
massive and then they banned him and
then he's still big it's like he's
bigger than he was before social media
he's not as big as he was when he was on
you know the big platforms
but he did an interview with me outside
the house and i got half a million views
in a day or something and i was just
like wow man wow i actually whenever i
uh post about him on social media now i
use
hashtag i use at ben stewart because you
have an account because he gets banned
i'm just like hashtag alex jones it's
good enough totally follow the hashtag
he's become a hashtag now he also did a
good job on michael malus's show you
know he stayed stayed calm you know
when did he when they when did he go on
and what did they argue about well i
mean to be honest like i didn't get
through more than 20 minutes because of
my day wouldn't allow it but i mean he
started off michael malus was just like
i'm gonna run through a bunch of first
i'm gonna tell you conspiracy theory
isn't just one thing a lot of people
love making things like super simplistic
but then he was like you know okay loch
ness monster he was like not real
bigfoot you know i don't believe it you
know and then you know go for tonkin and
he went like a history buff you know
into real good detail but he wasn't like
he wasn't alex jones i remember the
first time when he started yelling into
the microphone you know he wasn't doing
stuff like that they had a really chill
conversation it was a good one
you're welcome
you're welcome
when was that
oh man it was recently right it was i
mean it was definitely after maybe a
month after
the they were on the this show last time
and i think it was because this show he
was like listen i want to get you just
one-on-one
talking you know not with other people
just you
bring the volume down and it was a
really good show
i've been so intrigued watching alex
jones ideas because so many people
discard him out of hand and i'm like i
don't think you can safely do that i
think that he should be an inspiration
to kind of look into some of this stuff
for yourself because he says things that
are true in a way that's very hyperbolic
and i think it turns some people off
from it but it's like yo you should
check it out well everyone should be
held accountable for their actions and
there's a lot to say about individuals
and what they said before and um i'll
leave it at that
all right let's see we'll just do a
couple more here we'll go we'll do a
couple more here oh it's ten already ten
what a great show
all right so we got jordan vt says i
agree with you tim on the importance of
building culture disagreements happen in
society and demonstrating how to have a
conversation with opposing views on your
show can help build a stronger culture i
agree i agree
neil hamilton junior says luke is right
and that the patterns of bad actors
should be exposed tim you are correct
and that the way we do that matters
yeah i think i think uh
i think we're both right as long as you
don't manipulate people in order to try
to convince them that your side is
better i think that's the big difference
because and that needs to be addressed
here because if you're thinking humanity
is dumb and stupid you need to
manipulate them to think like you are
you're becoming what you're fighting and
that's what i want to not do and that's
why i think i had such a strong reaction
towards this myself so there's there's
we got one more and um the only one we
didn't get is the ben is right but this
is uh
tim's wrong luke's wrong ian's wrong is
right they got us lydia
i finally got by the way is andrew
bronco i disagree with something that
was not right no we do look really
similar yeah
uh
guys go to timcast.com become a member
we're gonna have a member segment we're
talking about the national guard and
like i guess the threat of disbanding
them or something that's wild and we got
some we got some new data out of the uk
as it pertains to coveted rates
this is something that youtube is like
would maybe even ban us for talking
about and this is a scientific day
that's
i guess real we swear a lot good times
well no i don't mean the members i
mentioned for the show in general that's
true like i'm not going to pretend i
believe something for the sake of trying
to make money i don't care i don't want
to do that
um but i really appreciate all of you
guys who watch and and give us your
support and appreciate what we do so you
can follow the show at tim castro you
can follow me at tim cast basically
everywhere uh you want to shout anything
out ben
yeah so i just premiered here in austin
they film with aubry marcus he's a
really cool influencer um but he did
seven days in darkness
um just to see what he could see and
that the film is out now aubrymarcus.com
we really go into it with a film that's
like an initiation we recreate some of
the visions like the dmt visions that he
had in there and it's let me just end on
this when you do go into darkness
something does happen with your pineal
gland your circadian rhythm and
endogenous dmt and that's why i'm
wearing the dmt quest shirt you guys
should watch dmt quest
documentary on youtube and then go to
benjoffstewart.com sign up become a
member i love you forever
are we going to do like a documentary
documentary or something welcome to the
machine i got charles eisenstein um
right now helping with like the future
of where technology could go
and so yeah i got i got some really good
people working on that but because i was
working on the aubrey marcus film i
haven't made much headway past
development i want to do something on
dmt i want to do like i really want to
explore that and get you know deep and
big and long like two hours i want i
want someone to go down to the shamans
in south america and like like a toad or
something no no no no i i just mean like
i want to know everything there is to
know about the research and the culture
and what they've been doing what they've
discovered with it dmt i think maybe one
of the most fascinating things to me
yeah it is you know what like this guy
john chavez dmt quest let's talk about
that afterwards yeah there's a lot of
there's also a lot of fraud shamans out
there so be careful with that but
there's also prisons in brazil using dmt
to help prisoners get over uh you know
being murderers and other there's crazy
stories surrounding it but to to what
you're saying maybe this is why space is
is so dark but that's another thing but
i remember watching your movies all the
way back in in the 2000s what was it
climatica and then was what was the
other one uh esoteric esoteric agenda
that was the one i was like wow that's
really cool i got to get to know you we
got to know each other uh it's good to
see you again thank you so much for
coming on i wish i would have brought my
uh jeff my bill gates is not a medical
doctor t-shirt to austin sadly i didn't
but if you want yours you can get it on
the best political shirts.com and of
course i have a youtube channel where i
was translating german once again on my
youtube channel which you definitely
want to watch i had a lot of fun doing
that on youtube.com forward slash we are
change thanks for having me great debate
let's go let's keep let's keep uh let's
keep uh sharpening the what is it
sharpening the iron or yeah yes the iron
is hot and now is the time to temper it
and that is what we are doing here with
you
you are amazing people thank you for
being here and chatting and letting us
know what you think of being part of
this i'm so happy to be here too i love
you i'm just going to say that i love
you all
thanks for coming man yeah
if you want to check out my website it's
ian crossland.net and i will catch you
guys later yeah and i just want to leave
you guys with a thought that carl jung
had which is that people don't have
ideas ideas have people people like bill
gates and george soros are living out an
idea that we're better off understanding
before we try to attack the symptoms of
the idea
linda you want to
hey just let me get my last word in like
i'm just kidding you guys can follow me
on twitter at sourpatchlids we will see
you all at timcast.com in the members
segment thanks for hanging out bye guys
you